What's up everybody?
It is I, Rich Roll, your host.
Here once again with Lord Adam Skolnick,
soon to be property owner.
(men laughing)
Rocking the Low Tide Boyz baseball hat today.
I am, yes.
Shout out to the Low Tide Boys.
Shut out, LTB.
How are you doing today?
You know, I wore this jacket for a couple of reasons.
Number one is right now I've transitioned
into baby secret service agent.
(Rich laughing)
What does that mean?
You know like when the babies start crawling,
but not just crawling, but crawling really fast?
Yes.
So now April and I have to triangulate
to make sure we have Zuma covered.
Mm-hmm.
So it's like, he'll be cruising,
and I'm looking for him around the corner.
I'll be like, you got him?
You got him?
Yeah, yeah, I got him.
Earpiece?
Yeah, I got him.
Yeah, you know, you got him.
It's on you, yeah.
Renegade, you got Renegade?
I got Renegade.
(Rich laughing)
That's the code name for Zuma?
I feel like Zuma is a code name.
Yeah, Zuma is the code name.
Renegade was Barack Obama's secret service code name.
Oh yeah, that's right.
That's what they called him during the campaign
and he kept it.
That's right.
So I'm borrowing that.
Well, good to see you.
Good to be.
Good to see you.
Back with you before we corrupt people
with our respective biases.
Yes.
(Rich laughing)
I should mention that what we do here
in this special version of the podcast that we call Roll On,
is we talk about a variety of matters that are just
of interest to us over the past couple of weeks.
We do a little bit of show and tell.
We share some wins of the week.
Good news.
We're about good news, right?
Usually.
And yes, once in a while,
(Adam laughing)
we're kind of back to good news today.
We're back to good news lately.
Yeah, and we also round it out
with some listener questions,
so if you guys want a question fielded
for Adam and I to discuss,
you can leave it on our voicemail at (424) 235-4626.
Also, before we dive in,
if you're watching this on the YouTubes,
please subscribe.
Same goes for Apple and Spotify.
On that note, quick shout out to our Clips channel.
We have a little nascent seedling or nurturing
with this channel,
but we did just hire a full-time editor.
All praise to AJ.
AJ.
Who's piloting it.
We're uploading two clips every single day,
and we'll probably increase that at some point.
So if you'd like to take quick peeks
into the plant-based meat and organic potatoes
of what we do here for each episode,
that is the place to do it.
So subscribe to that channel as well.
There's a link to it in the description below
and in the show notes,
or you can just search rich roll clips on YouTube.
Love it.
What is up?
Well the other reason I wore this coat is,
wait is it too soon to get the water?
You can get the water.
You can't,
you shouldn't get in the water in the first segment.
It's up to you.
That's sort of signals that you're nervous,
or you have some kind of anxiety disorder.
Or just like dehydrated.
(Rich laughing)
(Adam laughing)
I don't know if you're furiously sipping from the water
in the first 10 seconds of the podcast,
something might be awry.
Something's wrong in your life.
Yeah, yeah.
Secret service duties are dehydrating you.
I wouldn't want me as my secret service agent.
(Rich laughing)
No, went out of town this week for the first time.
Went up to the wine country behind Santa Barbara.
Nice.
Where it's really lovely in the hills there.
And it was one of those places where you have to wear
like nice clothes to get in for dinner.
Right.
And so I wore this also.
You wore that?
I haven't taken it off.
That's seen a lot of mileage in the last 72 hours
after being in your closet for 10 years.
(Adam laughing)
Exactly, you know me so well.
I feel so seen.
Right.
I also feel like you showed up in
a matching shirt today to me.
We are kind of matching.
Yeah, that's kind of on a kind of odd.
A kind of floral patterned buttoned down.
I know, so it's a good news day.
So there's that as well.
Everything is good though.
The big battle is coming up.
Excited about that.
Which big battle is that?
Remember the swim run big battle.
Oh right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hence the Low Tide Boyz hat.
Exactly, Nicolas Remires and team Envol
have launched this cool thing,
because there are frustrated swim runners
all over the world.
Really most of them are in Europe to be quite honest,
if we're gonna be fair,
but-
They're less frustrated in Europe,
'cause they're actually good at it.
Right, but they can't do it in Europe.
Right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're more vaccinated.
Although I just get an email from Otillo
saying they were opening back up or I didn't.
Okay.
I can't remember the details of that, but-
It's gone.
It's gone up and down.
Some races have been canceled.
Some have not.
And so it's kind of this chance to get race organizers,
some spotlight, have swim runners kind of join in something,
and take all of June.
So basically it's everyone who wants to join signs up
at Envol's website.
And basically you get points for every three kilometer
or more swim run that you do.
I believe it's three kilometers, three or five.
And a couple of Euro, your 30,
I think it's 30 Euros.
Something like that.
I'll tell you right now.
It is, no 13.
It's just 13 Euro.
And a couple of those bucks go to Sea Shepherd.
Oh nice.
And so it's pretty, pretty cheap to sign up.
And then you can, every, like I said,
every three K Swimrun, which is not much.
As long as you do two swims and two runs that you log,
you get a certain amount of points
and then you get a point per kilometer.
And if you do more than 10 kilometers,
you get even more points.
You get a little bonus per kilometer.
And when does it kick off?
Kicks off June 1st.
June one, right.
It's all of June
And Envol is spelled, E N V O L.
That's right.
Do you know the website?
Envolcoaching.net.
Okay, envolcoaching.net.
And I am on team, Low Tide Boyz.
You are?
I am.
You're really stepping it up.
Really?
In the Swimrun world.
You feel like I'm-
Making a name for yourself in Swimrun.
I think it's because I'm the only mainstream journalist
that has written about it twice.
(Rich laughing) You have, you have.
(Adam laughing)
I know.
I don't even consider myself a mainstream journalist,
but I have-
Two New York Times pieces
on Swimruns.
That's right.
Courtesy of yours truly sitting right here.
You know, you launched me.
And now, we were joking before the podcast.
We're like, we've become like a Swimrun podcast
that's not a Swimrun podcast.
Yes, you don't really quite yet-
This is not a Swimrun podcast.
No, you don't want to market yourself-
So we're talking a very small subsection
of the audience right now.
Although I feel like some of your audience
like is starting to, it's permeating out there.
They wanna get into it.
It's just filtering into
the unconscious collective beehive mind out there.
And you know the point is,
the big battle is the perfect time to try it.
You could do like really small amounts
of of kilometers or mileage.
You go out there, you swim for a quarter mile,
run for a mile, swim for quarter mile,
run for a couple of miles and you're home,
and you're good.
And you've got, and you can easily do that.
I did, from my door,
I used to love doing this 8K Swimrun,
which I will do again during this June big battle.
I stopped doing it during the winter,
'cause it gets just gets cold in that Swimrun suit,
but I'm back in the Swimrun suit without the legs
and really excited to get after it again.
It's cool.
Yeah.
You do need access to water.
We had a listener question about that
a couple of weeks ago, right?
I don't think-
A lot of the pools I think are starting
to open up right now.
I wonder if, I don't know the answer if-
I don't know what the deal is in California.
What Nicholas says about pool swims.
I would imagine pool swims are fine.
I'm sure they are.
Yeah.
How many people live on a coastline where
they have access to getting out in the open water?
I know.
You're taking our small subset of the audience
and dividing it into an infinitesimal number.
No, but I think that's a good thing.
I think we should, we could further polarize even more.
Get the people by the water to resent the people
without water or vice versa.
On the subject of pools and water.
I came across a story in the New York Times.
I didn't put this in the outline or in the show notes,
but maybe Blake can pull it up.
Your studies.
Blake search, New York City pool in the East River.
Oh, right.
Did you see this?
Yeah, New York Times just posted it.
Yes.
Right.
This is very cool.
So apparently the New York City has just approved
this project to build a floating pool in Dumbo,
right in the middle of the East River.
And it's got this bridge so it gets cut up.
It's like icebergs, but the East River.
Exactly, it's like icebergs you see
in the middle of the, yeah.
So it's not icebergs.
I should also say before we get a little deeper into this,
we're trying something new today.
We're upping our production technology game.
We've got this big monitor here.
So we're gonna do the whole thing where we pull up clips
and talk about them a little bit.
But what is that?
So that's two, there's two Olympic,
one Olympic size,
or one 25, one 50?
It looks like.
It looks like,
well definitely one 50 meter pool,
but it appears that it only has four lanes
like Blake if you scroll down,
you could see a mock-up of the pool.
That's a little bit more zoomed in.
Why does it look like a cross? (Adam laughing)
But what it also does,
and see how it's a cross.
So one way is, I believe it's four lanes of 50 meter.
Okay.
50 meters in distance.
I'm not sure what the other side
of the cross is in distance,
but also there's some kind
of technologically advanced filtration system,
so it's actually also cleaning the East River
at the same time.
I love it.
So there's
an environmental sustainability component
to this thing which is very cool.
Which is very cool.
I'm all for it.
Anyway, I thought take 'em-
I love, first of all, I love Dumbo.
It'll take 'em,
hopefully it'll take 'em less than 10 years to build it.
It looks super futuristic and cool.
And if that works,
it seems like something you could replicate
in all kinds of cities across the world.
It also looks with the sun rising and that-
It's well photographed.
Designed.
Or mocked out.
It looks like-
Rendered.
Like the Catholic church is behind it.
'Cause of the cross?
Yes.
Or it looks like a pot dispensary.
(Adam laughing)
It's like.
No, it's very cool.
It is cool.
Can you imagine if you lived in Brooklyn
and you could just cruise out and swim there every day?
That would be pretty cool.
It'd be amazing.
Yeah.
It is beautiful.
I wonder if it'll be open,
if they'll heat it for the winter months.
I think it said in the article it'll be open
for 15 weeks out of the year.
Yeah I would imagine-
First they gotta build it.
Is it a barge?
Like, does it move?
I don't think it moves.
Okay.
See, there's that walkway,
that kind of architectural path that looks pretty long.
That looks like quite a ways out in the river.
It does.
Anyway, super cool.
It's very exciting.
What else do we wanna talk about?
You know we should-
How are you?
You know what we need to do?
What?
Well yeah, first of all, I'm good.
I'm glad to hear it.
I have two things that I wanna talk about.
The first is that today I feel really good.
My energy is excellent,
but I would say since the last time that I saw you,
I've actually had a bit of a hard time.
Like I've been struggling,
like with, I wouldn't call it depression,
but just a lack of energy or enthusiasm for life.
Like just waking up.
Are we still in the pandemic?
Are we not in the pandemic?
Like I live out in a remote place.
So I'm already kind of deprived from a normal
or adequate amount of social interaction
with the exception of of coming to the podcast studio
and doing this thing.
Right.
And I just found myself confused and also just having,
just being challenged to focus.
Yeah.
Or feel plugged in to life.
And it's, it left me like it, it impacted my sleep.
It impacted my ability to train.
Like I was really having a difficult time
just getting out there and getting active.
And I came across an article,
this article is from a couple of weeks ago,
it's by a friend of the pod, Adam Grant.
Oh.
Called "Feeling Blah During the Pandemic:
It's Called Languishing."
And I think languishing is a word that perfectly
captures how I've been feeling up
until literally this morning.
That's how you, that's your, that's your,
that's your inner self?
Yeah, that's me before I.
That's your inner self?
Before I cut my hair right.
(Adam laughing)
Staring at a muffin.
I don't know what that is or no, an orange.
And I think,
we'll link this article up in the show notes,
but Adam I think really perfectly captures this.
I don't know if it's an epidemic,
but a lot of people are having this experience right now.
It's fairly common even though I felt like I was
the only person who was experiencing it.
And reflecting upon it,
I think if you really think about it,
we've just gone through an unbelievable year
of insane political turmoil of stay at home orders,
of being afraid initially to even touch our groceries,
and we're sanitizing everything,
and we're terrified of our interactions
with other human beings.
And now as we start to emerge out of it,
I think we're in a stage of dealing with,
I mean I wouldn't go so far as
to call it post-traumatic stress,
but there is a stress that we've all weathered.
And I think without confronting it and really,
in our own respective individual ways,
finding a way to work through it,
you can't just expect that it would disappear.
It's like, oh, back,
we're back in the world now.
Like, everything's fine.
Like that was a crazy year.
Like we've just gone through,
even look obviously,
some have had it much worse than others.
And I've had a pretty charmed version of this year,
but at the same time,
I've still, I still think about the,
everything that we've kind of gone through collectively
has an impact on our psyche.
And the isolation.
Like we went through the isolation collectively.
Where usually being alienated is kind of,
you feel like the only one.
This time everyone is kind of doing that at the same time,
but that doesn't lessen the impacts of it.
Sure, but now we're in this stage of like,
we're good, right?
Are we good?
Like, let's go.
We went to, we went-
Can we go, can we,
like you were in a hotel room, right?
For the first time.
Like first hotel room in a while.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like I'm sure when you walked into that room,
you're like okay, like, are we okay?
Is everything good?
Like-
You're talking to someone who is like
a professional travel writer for a decade.
Like I was on the road nine months a year
for Lonely Planet alone in a lot of these places.
And to be back in the hotel,
like we we were thinking about going to Hawaii
for 10 days or so,
and then we just couldn't get our minds
around bringing the baby on the airplane yet.
We just weren't quite comfortable with that yet.
So we decided let's give this,
let's do something really simple, the first step.
And it was comfortable.
And, you know, you got to eat in a restaurant
for the first time.
It's like big advances.
We got to see a bunch of animals and have
a good time with them.
Like at a,
like a petting zoo.
It was hilarious.
It was good, but it was the first time.
And there was this reticence.
There was this kind of hesitation.
I would suggest potentially another aspect of this for you,
'cause I felt it myself a bunch of times,
the re-entry process after doing
a super highly concentrated intense story
in a different location then coming home,
you don't really notice it.
It takes like a week for you to settle in.
And after that, you're like, whoa,
nothing really matters as much as what
that experience was like.
And so the adrenaline pumping and the high and being
on location during a very intense period of time,
this is right when the verdict was happening.
This is like,
there was another shooting.
And you're out there for that talking
to people deeply involved in it.
And then you come back,
it's gonna take awhile for you to feel like
the other podcasts matter as much as those podcasts matter.
That's not to say that it doesn't,
it's just a feeling sometimes.
I'm suggesting, I'm projecting,
but I've had that with stories where I feel.
Sure.
Yeah, yeah.
It's, you know, it's that scene of Jeremy Renner walking,
wandering down the grocery aisles like pining to be back
in a combat situation.
Right, right.
You know what I mean?
And you understand why people of that ilk feel like they
have to continue to redeploy,
or war correspondents.
Exactly.
Like Dan Harris has spoken about this.
Like he basically was like,
I was addicted to being dispatched to all these crazy places
and being right in the middle of some insanity.
And then you come home and everything is just blah
and muted in comparison to that.
And Sebastian Younger I think just the documentary now,
he's got his book out about the same thing,
bringing this group of guys,
some of them are military,
Some of them were correspondents together,
and they're like walking the rails together.
Their trying to kind of come to terms with
what they went through.
Right, right.
So I guess what you're saying is that what we're
all collectively experiencing is a tiny version of that.
I think that's true.
And then I think specifically you given the timeframe
that we're talking about just still about a month
since you got back,
maybe a little bit more.
Mm yeah, I don't know.
Maybe a little projection in that.
I'm not so sure that it's rooted in the trip
to Minneapolis as much as it is a reckoning
with the last 14, 15 months.
Fair enough.
But I feel good today.
You feel good today?
So I'm on the other side of it.
That's the thing.
That's the thing about emotions,
even when you think you're stuck in some cycle
that you can't escape from,
they tend to always change.
You just gotta wait for the-
Feelings are just feelings, man.
Feelings are feelings, right?
Well, that's like this weird moment that we're
in is also this,
everyone's in their feelings so much,
and it makes you want,
it makes me want to be in them less.
Like I want to be in mine less.
I wanna feel less.
Mm.
Is that weird?
Is that bad?
I'm trying to wrap my head around what you mean.
So basically because of just the dissonance
and the vitriol that's out there right now.
Yes, yes.
Like just go out and have an analog experience
and enjoy your life.
Yeah, just go out and just like touch the ocean
and be in awe.
Yeah, I feel you.
Yeah.
Well speaking of getting in touch with our feelings,
I think we do need to talk about the Brogan situation
a little bit.
I don't know that you and I need to process this very much.
I think we're good.
Right, you and I?
We're good, yeah?
Now that my operatives have gotten to you.
Yes, right.
Well done, well done team.
Talk about impacting my psyche,
but I feel like maybe we need to process this a little bit
for the audience.
Yes, let's do it.
The Brogan thing continues to resurface it's head.
I've been on the receiving end of quite a few emails
and comments posted on social media that I'm still being
too mean to you,
and that I need to be nice to you.
And you know, Brogan will never take your job.
And how dare I court affections with an interloper
such as him.
How dare you?
A giant man with a huge heart and a big personality.
(Adam laughing) Yeah.
So just to be clear, I guess I can be nicer to you.
It was all, it's all been in good fun.
I thought we talked about this last time.
Yeah, we did a little bit.
Tongue and cheek.
But it continued to crop up a little bit,
because then I put up Brogan's episode.
Oh, right.
Which was the other week, so.
Yes, and that was when he first
kind of broached the subject.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Threw the gauntlet down.
But that little video that he texted me today
that I sent you,
there's a clip in there where he's like,
he's like, "Send me Skolnik's info.
I'm gonna be friends with that guy."
(Adam laughing)
He's just a big cousin, friend hunter.
So mad love for Brogan.
Yes.
But for all of you out there,
in the podcast universe, Adam's job is secure here.
My love for Adam runs deep.
Thank you, sir.
Nobody's taking that chair away from you.
Igualmente.
Although we may have Brogan come out,
and in that case,
perhaps we should do
a plant-based leather couch intervention situation.
We can get a therapist involved.
We can talk it all through.
Yeah, I would love that.
Come to some-
I have a lot to say.
Place of love and consensus over the whole thing.
I'm just glad that my ground swell
of supporters out there.
It's growing.
It's growing and they gathered
with pitchforks and torches just like I suggested.
Came to your defense.
Right.
Stridently.
I had nothing to do with that, Rich.
(Rich laughing)
Yeah, you weren't using Fiverr to like beg.
We were on, we have a group on Parlor.
(men laughing)
Okay, okay so we've cleared that up right?
Yes.
We're all good.
Yeah.
What else do we wanna talk about?
We should come-
Well you have to talk about what you've been doing,
'cause I know that you're in a different phase
than you've been in for awhile.
Yeah, I mean, we're gonna get into that
I think in the bigger theme,
after the ad break.
Okay, fair enough.
I've been writing,
I've been kind of in the,
down the rabbit hole with that.
And it's been fairly all consuming in a good way,
but not without its drawbacks,
so we'll talk about that after the break.
I think we should get into two noteworthy newsworthy topics.
The first is this ultra race tragedy in China that happened.
Well, I found out about it on Sunday morning.
It must have happened on Saturday,
where extreme weather killed 21 ultra marathoners
in this race.
Crazy.
Blake, can you pull up that first article about this.
The Yellow Riverstone Forest 100k,
I believe is what it's called.
A 100 kilometer race.
In Gansu Province.
Have you been to that part of the world?
I'm not familiar with what the terrain is.
I've been just, my only experience in mainland China
is Beijing and just outside at the Great Wall.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
So scroll up a little bit.
I believe that in the early miles of this race,
they were,
Blake scroll up so I can read the article.
I mean, scroll down.
They were faced with 6,300 feet of elevation gain
or I don't know where, what elevation gain they started at,
but essentially these runners were all in shorts
and lycra and just the lightest gear.
And in short shrift,
the weather turned pretty dire pretty quickly,
such that a lot of these participants got caught
in a rainstorm that turned into a hailstorm.
Temperatures dropped precipitously.
And really bad winds.
And it became incredibly dangerous.
And these people were trapped.
They couldn't get their footing.
The terrain was super rugged.
Apparently it was already scrambling kind of terrain.
Like people were on their hands and knees
and still getting blown over.
Right, yeah.
21 people.
Out of 172.
I mean that's got to be the biggest death toll
in the history of multi-sport.
I don't know of any other event where
that many people perished.
I mean it's crazy.
How could it be more than that?
Like, 'cause it takes a tragedy.
Apparently several others could have died,
but like they huddled in caves or they,
like one guy in the top six of the runners,
the only one that survived he thinks was carried
by a shepherd.
He blacked out on the mountain and was carried
by a shepherd down to a cave and a fire was started
and then others joined them in there.
Others went down the hill into,
into I guess the structures that rescuers sent them into.
Apparently the winds were tearing
through the space blankets.
It was that bad.
And so people had space blankets.
It's not like that these people were all kind
of super green or under prepared.
People had space blankets.
They might not have had the technical gear you needed,
but they had that and it didn't work.
Yeah, and that one particular athlete that was saved
by the shepherd,
I think passed out and came to in a cave.
Yep, right, right, right
And didn't even know what had happened.
Didn't know he got carried down there.
Right.
Guy saved his life.
There was one guy who perished,
I think his name is Liang Jing.
Yep.
I'm sure I'm butchering that name.
Who was a champion ultra runner.
A Hong Kong guy.
Like there was a field of really fast people.
I'm sure it was a wide spectrum of talent and ability,
but the fact that that many people died.
I know it was a huge story all across China.
There's gonna be I'm sure,
a massive investigation into this.
And I think what's instructive about it is
a conversation around the safety measures
when you host an event like this.
And I think in particular ultra running
or ultra trail running,
being this sport that is growing very rapidly,
it's still an emerging sport.
But it's gone from, it's kind of grassroots,
dirt bag, hippie, sleep in a tent at the starting line vibe
to legitimate,
a legitimate sport that's attracting more and more people.
And I think with that comes a responsibility
to have your shit together for something like this.
It seems like the race should just
have been called off because like with weather
coming in in altitude.
I can't imagine they didn't know
that there was a solid chance
that the weather would turn in such a way.
Maybe they didn't.
I don't know.
It doesn't seem,
it seems like that that would be
where you'd start the investigation.
In terms of the rescue,
1,200 people turned out and comb those mountains
in really bad conditions for, searching for people.
And they rescued a lot of them.
I mean, it could have been a lot worse.
I mean, I should say kudos to the rescue,
search and rescue team,
which I've always admired search and rescue people.
But 1,200 people getting out there to help out a
is quite a number.
Right, but that's reactive safety
as opposed to prophylactic safety.
Yeah, that's government versus the organizers.
Yeah I would imagine that all race organizers
are gonna think twice now and it's gonna mean
that race organizers are gonna have to have
those prophylactic safety measures in place.
If the terrain is such that it could lead
to something like this,
which means the races are going to be more costly.
And it's.
Insurance.
I think it's a shifting of the tide as this sport
grapples with how it's going to mature and grow.
But it makes me think about the Otillo race in Sweden
when were doing the pig swim and the boats
are getting thrashed around.
I was like, this is crazy.
Like this would never have been allowed to continue
in the United States.
Even Catalina people come in,
come in from the long distance.
You, you, I think you just came out for the one day,
but if you'd stayed the second day.
It was so calm that day.
Yeah, but the second day wasn't.
Winds were howling.
Water temp dropped a bit and they're out there longer.
And the last third of the race is mostly swim
with just a little runs, connecting the swims.
And so there's not enough of a run to get you warm.
And I think it's similar to how the race ends
or no maybe, I don't, maybe not.
I don't know, but that's how the race ended there.
And people came in.
I was concerned about several people
who came in completely shivering,
blue lips, the whole thing.
Luckily, there was warm showers right there
and they could take care of it.
It is a little bit different
than extreme altitude and extreme weather.
The altitude,
I think the altitude with the ice weather
and then people were apparently,
some of these runners were foaming at the mouth.
Like, so how fast did the,
did you get to pulmonary edema?
Like how fast that happens?
It's so tragic.
It's tragic.
21 people, it's crazy.
Crazy.
So heartbroken for all of these people
and their families.
Of course.
Who are suffering as a result of this
and for China's trail running community in general.
It's just an awful tragedy.
Well, that's what they're saying
about the Hong Kong ultra marathon community
is like really staggered by this.
They've all lost lots of friends.
I'm sure, I'm sure.
Yeah.
It can't be that big of a community.
So and there were people interviewed in the piece like,
oh, this was my friend or I lost two friends.
Like everybody who's part of that subculture I'm sure
is one or two people away from being connected
to somebody who passed.
When you did some ultras were you always careful
to check the weather yourself
and make sure that you were carrying like heavy gear
for cold or like-
Well I'm not,
I'm not gonna hold myself out as
a super experienced ultra runner.
Like I haven't done these kinds of races.
Like I've done Ultraman where you have a crew
following you the whole time.
Like you're being monitored constantly.
It's very different.
Plus it was in Hawaii.
It's not the same thing.
No.
I mean the biggest threat there is being hit
by a car or getting attacked by jellyfish.
But you're not gonna die of hypothermia.
No, no, no.
In Hawaii, so.
All right, well let's,
let's switch gears here a little bit.
I think it's time to check in on the Iron Cowboy
with our Iron Cowboy moment.
Our ticket.
Let's do it.
He's on day 85 now.
Unbelievable.
It's so crazy.
I can't even believe it.
Day 85 and he actually looks great.
I feel like he's in a new gear.
I keep saying that.
He's in better shape now than when like day 20.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So today is Monday.
He's on day 85.
This will go up Thursday.
So anything could happen between now and then,
but yesterday day 84, he said he felt better
than he had in the last three weeks.
He seems to be ending the marathon every day in daylight
which is unbelievable, which means he's getting more rest.
He's allowing his body a little bit more to recover,
which is cool.
His spirits are very high.
Like he just seems super engaged with,
with his community
All the people that are there to support.
I just, I love seeing his little speeches
at the end of the night after he finishes a marathon.
He's so gracious with the people who've traveled all over
to come and run or bike with him.
It's very cool.
Jesse Itzler dropped in on him the other day.
Jesse posted, I think it was yesterday or today,
that one of the biggest things that he took away
from it was just how much his family is a part of this.
Like the fact that his his wife is basically running
the whole thing, his kids,
his daughter's running the social media.
He's got a son out there with him.
Like the whole family is involved
and then he's got his wing man.
And he's got this other sort of outer, more outer,
in the concentric circle of support of people
that are helping him.
And he's a leader.
Like he's able to like engender the level
of like support and love from all of these people
who are devoting their time.
I mean his whole family is basically all about it right now.
It's crazy.
And he takes calls on the marathon.
(men laughing)
Mm, I know, yeah he does.
But he,
his daughter is as well,
also not just social media,
she's handling like the media relations as well.
She is, right.
And sponsor relationships.
Yeah, yeah.
Like it's like a full time job what she's doing.
And she's 18 I'm pretty sure.
Right, I know, I know.
Yeah, yeah.
It's pretty cool.
It's amazing.
So are you gonna go out there?
Yes, I'll be there the last few days of the-
You are?
Yes.
My goal is to be there the last,
part of the last,
the third to the last day.
And then the last full day is the last two days.
Pretty exciting.
Yeah, get out there.
So you can do multiple Ironmans, right?
I am, my goal is,
part of my job is gonna be to like chronicle
his experience and everything,
but the other part of it is to kind of take note
of the community response and how people are just turning
out and kind of that herd of support,
which is super inspiring to see,
the Forrest Gump effect.
That's what we're trying,
it's what we're calling it.
And so I'll be taking that temperature as well.
So that's going to include finishing at least one
of the marathons with him,
which I feel like,
I've never even run more than 11 miles at once,
but this is like a run-walk and I've walked,
I've walked 26 miles in a day a couple of different times.
And I'm in good shape for it,
so I think I'll be maybe the last one
is what I'll shoot for, but we'll see.
So he's scheduled to finish on June 8th.
Yes.
If all goes to plan, correct?
Yes, yes, yes.
I gotta see what I can do.
We've gotta get you out there.
Can't make any promises.
I'm juggling a lot of responsibilities
with a lot of different people right now in my household.
I know, I know.
I'm definitely gonna make a point of trying
to get out there.
I don't know that I can be out there on the final day,
but I know if I don't find a way to do that,
I'll be super bummed.
(Adam laughing) Bring the whole family.
That's one way of doing it.
Life is about experiences.
That's, I can tell you, I can promise you,
that's not gonna happen.
(Adam laughing)
Yeah, that's is not gonna happen.
Pile in, rent a minivan Rich.
Yeah, I don't want to publicly say,
make any promises that I can't live up to,
but I'm looking into it.
Fantastic.
So we'll see what happens,
but much love to the Iron Cowboy and his whole family.
It's just, it's so impressive what he's doing.
It's it's unbelievable.
And the fact that his body is acclimating to this
and holding up and just remarkable.
And you talk to him on the phone and he's like,
it's like he's sitting at a desk
or like sitting on his couch.
Did you speak to him on the phone?
I've spoken to him twice now.
Cool, cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And he's just like so inspired and inspiring.
He posted the other day.
Maybe it was yesterday, I can't remember.
It was like, something like,
someone asked him,
"How do you know if you're gonna get through a given day?"
He says, "I know it the minute I set my foot in the water,"
or something like that.
Like he already knows.
Like he wakes up knowing.
Did you see?
It must've been 80, maybe 82 or 83,
right before he was about to get into the pool
'cause he never posts any videos until the swim is over.
Right.
But he was struggling to get his head around
beginning another day.
And he teared up.
Like he got emotional.
He's like,
he started crying and he was like, "I'm gonna try."
"I'm just gonna, I'm gonna try."
And that was it.
Like you could tell the exhaustion level
was just beyond imaginable.
Hmm, I did not know about that.
Day 82, 83.
It was, it might've been day 83.
It's weird, because if you're,
the Instagram stories disappear, right?
So if you're not on it, you miss it.
But I would certainly ask him about that.
It appeared to be,
who knows what he's also not sharing,
but it appeared to be quite a low moment for him.
And then to see him rally back
and then a day or two later,
big smile, lots of energy.
And I've never once seen him short or curt with anyone.
He's nothing but like gracious.
Every word that comes out of his mouth is positive.
And you know,
there's a powerful lesson in that for all of us I think.
No doubt, man.
No doubt.
So sending you love and strength.
Let's take a quick break and we'll be right back
with the big theme.
The big theme.
(whooshing)
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already
know how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables, seeds,
beans, and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly however,
without the kitchen tools and support very few end up
sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is The Plant Power Meal Planner.
Our are affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people.
For just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHealth for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Adam took two drinks of his water during the break.
He didn't want anyone to see or hear,
but it happened right.
I gasped, I gasped.
Are we, are you okay?
Don't make me sick my minions upon you.
Yeah, that Fiverr account you better,
you better put a little more money in there.
It is true.
I am slightly dehydrated Rich.
Mm, well, all those secret service duties.
I might have been heavy on the salt
at last night's dinner.
That plus the secret service duties,
plus the new cycle.
But not about the Swimrun training
where you're swallowing salt water off Point Doom.
You know what I've been training in the bay.
Back to Swimrun.
We can't stop talking about Swimrun.
Well, swimming in general.
So I've been,
Nicholas has been trying to get me to do drills
with swimming and I I've always not done it,
but the last two swims I've actually been trying to
and he sends like these drills that are obviously shorthand
and every swimmer who's been,
ever swam like from age 10 on knows what he's talking about.
But you need a decoder ring.
But I have no idea.
You should just
send them to me,
I'll decode it for you.
So anyway, I'm kind of trying to figure it out.
But I was out there swimming and was surrounded
by dolphins and having such a great time.
And great whites.
You just didn't see 'em.
I know, but that's okay.
Right, right.
I felt good,
but there was one really murky area right
after the dolphin area,
and I'm like, hmm.
(Rich laughing)
Not so good.
(Rich laughing) No.
All right, well,
the big theme that we're gonna talk about today.
Big theme.
Has to do with balance,
which is a subject that's come up many times
in the history of this podcast.
The idea of living a balanced life or living your life
in pursuit of balance.
And I wanna talk about this in the context
of what I'm grappling with right now.
As we mentioned prior to the break,
I've been writing,
I've been on a writing jack lately.
I'm working on putting together Volume Two
of "Voicing Change."
And what's interesting about this is that
this book is very much a team effort.
I've got designers.
I've got people who know how to do book layouts.
I've got graphics people.
I've got Georgia,
who's helping me with some of the writing on it.
And you know they've been doing this for months
at this point.
So every two weeks we do a Zoom call.
It's an update on where they're at,
and they're progressing like very methodically
and gradually through the manuscript.
And I have this guilt and shame every time I get
on one of these Zoom calls,
because I've done nothing.
(Adam laughing)
And they're like, Rich, you need,
we need this, this, and this from you,
you gotta do it.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I just could not get off my ass
and start working on this thing.
And Greg would be like just work on it like
an hour or two a day,
just chip away at it.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like intellectually, rationally,
that makes sense,
but I just couldn't make that happen.
But now we have looming deadlines,
and deadlines are very effective in getting,
catalyzing you to get on it.
Mainly out of fear.
But I've been paralyzed to just begin.
But I finally cracked the seal a couple of weeks ago.
And what happens in my experience is that when I crack
that seal and I just start,
suddenly I become not just invested in it,
but it becomes like all consuming.
Like it starts to monopolize my focus.
And the only thing I wanna do is work on it.
So this obsession kicks in where I
then crowd out everything else in my life,
and just go down the rabbit hole.
And I just work on it for like 12 hours a day
and exhaust myself.
And then I wake up at 3:00 in the morning and start working.
It's crazy.
Mm-hmm, right.
It's not balanced.
Right away you get into that mode
or does it a few days?
Well there's a little bit of a lead up,
and then it kicks in.
It's like addiction.
And I've just become a full-blown addict where
it's like the relief,
there's a relief in sitting back down
and being engaged with it,
and there's also this sense of impending greater relief
that you're nearing a certain finish line.
And there's a discomfort with
not working more quickly towards that.
And as a book writer,
I'm sure you've experienced this, right?
Yes, I relate to this, not,
with basically any assignment I'm working on.
The hardest part is getting yourself to actually start.
I remember with "One Breath" I was terrified,
because I had spent the better part of a year researching.
And I had all this research, now is was time to act.
I had an outline.
Now it's time to actually do it.
And I was terrified that I couldn't do it.
I had like two and a half months to write a book.
Did you have a,
like an extended period of paralysis though
before you actually?
Yeah I think,
I think like-
Started getting on it.
I could have started writing it
while I was still researching it,
but I told myself,
no, you gotta do the research first,
and then I didn't,
I couldn't,
luckily in that situation,
I couldn't afford to have the paralysis.
So I've had extended periods of paralysis
with the current book I'm writing with my-
Well deadlines will cure you of supposed writer's block.
Right, there was no-
That we like to indulge in.
There was no chance of paralysis for that.
So I just dove in,
but what you're talking about is the pressure is on you,
and you feel the pressure.
And then as soon as you start,
especially in a writing process, I find,
you get some ease right away.
You feel like, okay, I can now see myself.
If I just do that again.
I can get to the end.
And then once you're past that-
Well, it's like a locomotive.
The first part is so slow and then you hit
a certain inflection point where you're like,
okay, I feel like I know what I'm doing.
I wouldn't say downhill, but you hit it a stride.
Yeah, and you get the momentum,
and that carries you and then yeah.
Yeah, momentum is so powerful.
It's such a self perpetuating energy source.
It's so difficult to covet,
but once you have it,
I feel like it's so important to protect it
against everything else,
because it's fleeting.
Like if that momentum gets drained somehow,
I just know all too well how difficult it is
to get back into that state where you can allow
the momentum to propel you forward.
Yeah, it takes consistency to get back to the momentum,
'cause if you have it going,
then you have to take a break,
then it's gonna take a couple of days for you
to get back into the groove.
Yeah, so this process for me,
always connects me with like guilt and shame,
'cause I feel like why can't I just work on it responsibly
an hour or two a day?
Then I would be in lockstep with my team who
has been doing that all along rather than trying
to play catch up,
which makes me feel even guiltier.
But I've learned,
Julie's always like,
"It's 'cause you love it this way.
You love it.
Don't complain.
You're not allowed to complain about this,
because you always do this."
Like there's some part of you that likes it
or get something out of it, right?
Even if it's an unhealthy habit,
it's still doing something for me,
which is why I keep doing it.
The procrastination creates pressure,
and the pressure creates better work.
Yeah, so the way I rationalize it is
this is what I need to do to do my best work.
Like I can't just pop in and out,
because it's in hour six that things really start
to come together.
And it's that experience of immersion
where you're just totally all in,
and the rest of the world disappears,
that you put yourself in the position
for that like extra piece to come out.
I think there's something to that.
I don't think it's a hard and fast rule,
but I think it's something to that.
Like if you're really under the gun,
that's when and you're you're living and breathing it,
there's no separation.
Certainly you can have some great moments of inspiration,
but you can also have them on a walk in the middle
of that kind of experience.
Okay, I'm gonna take a walk,
I'm going to go outside and catch my breath.
I know.
Then it comes to you.
So I don't, I've,
a long while ago,
I kind of stopped trying to figure out
what the perfect conditions are for writing or what the,
the best place to do it or how to do it,
or this process or that process.
You just have to do it in whatever way you can get to it.
The fact that this is your process now is great.
And you know Rob Bell says every project will demand
maybe a slightly different process from him.
I look at him and this is total projection,
but it just appears that it flows effort effortlessly,
like out of that guy,
'cause he's such a constant font of creative output.
And I have this unhealthy thing,
which is if it doesn't hurt,
then you didn't push yourself hard enough,
and it could have been better.
Which is at odds with this idea that I've tried to embrace,
but I've been unable to master,
which is what if it were easy, right?
Like what if it just flowed?
Like what if it were easy?
What if you let go of that story that revolves around
the grind and what comes out of the grind,
and you just allowed yourself to be in a space
where it just comes because you're in the allowing
rather than in the forcing.
Interesting.
And that's the mountain that I've tried to climb.
and I'm still at the base of that mountain,
I would say.
Well like-
But I have had,
go ahead, sorry.
No, no, please.
I also get accused of interrupting you too much.
I think I interrupt you constantly.
(Rich laughing)
I've interrupted people my entire career.
At the beginning it was really bad.
I'd listen to the interview tapes and I'd cringe at myself.
It's gotten a little better, but I do it to you as well.
But all I was gonna suggest was that if you look
at sports or if you look at how you got better
at a certain thing in athletics,
has it ever been through just easing up?
No and that's the lens that I use,
because my narrative is everything that I've been able
to accomplish as a result of me being willing
to out grind everybody else and work harder.
Right.
It's not a talent thing.
It's a grit thing.
And so that's my default,
but I'm not so sure that that is the healthiest,
and it's certainly not the most sustainable,
because it's exhausting.
So I go, I do these mad sprints,
and then I'm depleted and then I need to recover.
As opposed to what I would imagine
or what I project onto Rob Bell,
which is that he's just consistently creating all the time.
And I'm not saying it's effortless for him,
but he would appear to have a healthier relationship
with his inner muse such that he's not,
like he doesn't hold himself out as somebody
who gets exhausted,
because he's creating.
No I think it's easier to be prolific
if you're doing a little bit at a time every day.
Like the Hemingway thing from 6:00 AM to noon,
and then he's at the bar kind of thing.
Yeah, I think Ryan Holiday does a good job of that too.
Like he talks a lot about that.
Like he's just constructed his life so that these
are the hours that he does the thing.
And he does it no matter what.
It's a Steven Pressfield approach to the whole thing.
And I really aspire to master that.
I have a lot of other moving pieces in my life
at the same time.
When I wrote "Finding Ultra" it was different.
That was the only thing that was happening.
But now there's a lot going on.
And so figuring out how to squeeze that in
while these other things are still on track
has been the challenge for me.
But one thing that I have done is try to be
a little bit more gentle on myself,
and rather than indulge in that guilt or that shame,
like why can't I do it that way?
Why do I always set myself up for this?
And why am I putting myself in this position?
But to just kind of let go of that and say,
look for whatever reason, this is my predisposition,
this is how I'm wired,
and at least for right now,
I'm going to embrace that aspect of me and let go
of trying to judge myself against some imaginary standard
of what a balanced person's life looks like.
And I think the reason that I wanted to bring this up today,
isn't to like talk about my personal experience,
but as an instructive,
kind of a launchpad to talk about something I think
is very common with a lot of people,
which is this idea of living a balanced life.
What does it mean to pursue a life of balance?
And is that something that we should even aspire to do?
Right?
What do you think?
I don't know.
Well, I think that sets people up for failure.
And I think most people have some version
of what I experience,
which is a sense that they can't live up to that.
They have this idea,
they look out into the world and they see person X
who seems to be excelling in their life in all categories,
and they say, "How can I be a great mom
and be a professional at my job,
and make sure that there's food on the table
and also go to the PTA meetings and all the stuff, right?
Right, right.
Like, and it sets up an unrealistic set of parameters
or expectations for the average person.
So my whole thing is letting go of that and focusing not
on how you can be balanced on an everyday basis
and all the things that you're trying to do better at,
but rather focus on the thing that you are doing
in the moment and be the best version of yourself
that you can in that moment.
And understand that nobody can do everything
every single day well.
So it's more like a toggle switch of being invested
in what you're doing in the moment,
and then switching gears to the next thing.
Like I can't,
first of all, multitasking is a misnomer.
There's no such thing as multitasking,
but we still have this idea that we like switch gears
and go back and forth from other things.
And some people are better at that than others.
And I've learned that I'm not good at that.
I'm good at doing one thing well,
and then slowly moving to the next thing and focusing
on doing that thing well.
But I can't toggle switch back and forth
within a single day.
My wife is very good at that.
Greg Anzalone is very good at that.
It's a different set of skill,
so it's about understanding what your strengths are
and what your weaknesses are,
and then trying to orient your life around addressing those
rather than guilting yourself into why you can't do it
like somebody else is doing it.
Maybe that's your balance.
Your balance is I do one thing at a time really well.
And that's how you feel the most balanced.
Like what does it even mean to be balanced?
Does it mean that you can do X, Y and Z
at this incredibly high level?
'Cause that doesn't seem balanced to me.
That just seems like (Adam chuckles) great aptitude
for work.
Well, how are we measuring balance?
And what is the timeframe?
And one of the things I'm always talking about
is expanding the window upon which you're evaluating
your ability to live a balanced life.
There you go.
If you're looking at on it,
if you're looking at it through the microscope
of your daily routine,
most people are gonna fall short of that.
I failed miserably at that.
But if you look at it over a long continuum,
then you're giving yourself larger bandwidth to say,
okay I'm doing this one thing now,
but what are the other things in my life that are important
that are not getting as much attention as they should.
When I finish this,
then I gotta make sure that those things are in order
and in the background,
the other things that are important need a little bit
of daily nourishment,
but perhaps aren't going to be getting your full attention.
But then understanding like,
okay, when that's done,
then I need to reconfigure my life to focus
on these other things.
So over the course of several months or a year,
then it looks like it's in balance.
Right.
But when you look at it on a,
like if you look at my life on a day-to-day basis,
it's completely out of balance.
So Brad Stulberg,
the other week we talked about Steve Magness,
we used his kind of quote and something that he had written
as a topic for discussion.
Steve's writing partner is Brad Stulberg,
who's also been on the podcast,
New York Times contributor, Outside Magazine contributor.
Have you ever met Brad?
I have not.
You'd like him, he's great.
But he's written extensively about this subject.
And one of the things that he said is that,
"A lot of people swallow this cultural message
of balance, balance, balance.
Then they struggled to find it,
and they get down on themselves,
because they can't do it everything every single day.
They think I'm going to wake up.
I'm gonna have some family time.
I'm gonna go to work from nine to five.
I'm gonna come home, more family time, cook dinner,
watch a TV show, go to sleep.
But that's only one way to think about balance."
And this is where I really resonate with Brad.
He says, "Try thinking about balance being
over a long continuum.
This gives you permission to go all in for periods of time.
That way you can experience flow
and still have a balanced life.
It's just that the balance might be over five or 10 years
not every single day.
And a corollary to that is this idea that
rather than striving for balance,
striving for self-awareness instead.
The ability to know your core values and evaluate
the trade-offs inherent in pursuing them."
And I love that.
It's also the subject of a New York Times piece
that he wrote called,
"Maybe We All Need a Little Less Balance."
Someone is quoted in that,
someone is quoted in there.
I know.
I pulled that article up.
I'd forgotten that he referenced me in it.
Just not why I'm bringing it up,
but I just think it's a great read for helping people
recalibrate how you think about these things.
And despite the fact that I've been,
droning on and on about this for a long time,
I found myself in the process of working
on this book project to go right back to that level
of self judgment that's counterproductive
rather than just saying,
this is what I'm doing now,
for whatever reason here I am back again doing this thing
I said I wasn't gonna do again.
Which is going down the rabbit hole
and blocking out everything else and not doing it
in a more managerial kind of way,
but this is the way that I do it.
And that's okay.
Yeah, I mean, I'm totally with that.
I think like this idea of balance,
this idea of finding your passion,
and following your passion or finding the one,
these are all somewhat cultural myths, to some extent.
And to me,
we are here on earth to find ourselves first,
and that requires some self-reliance and independence,
but it also requires some mutual dependence
and interconnection.
And it's all,
it's all this like equation that we're trying
to find the answer to.
I mean, equanimity is kind of like a corollary
to enlightenment, right?
When you find,
like when the person,
the Bodhisattva has meditation to achieve equanimity
is to achieve enlightenment.
Well, what does equanimity mean?
Right.
It means,
no one achieves it in their day-to-day life.
And so yes,
in terms of how do you get the best conditions
for you to feel comfortable in your skin,
comfortable in your life,
having your family do well,
having your career do well, all that balance sheet.
It seems, to me,
we're talking like life's balance sheet
and it's like that's a moving,
those graphs are like jumping up and down.
And I think when it comes to writing,
two things come to mind.
Number one is you just have to get the work done
and you have to live with those critics.
Like the guy,
the hecklers from "The Muppet Show" in your head
that are going to constantly be jabbering,
not to date myself,
but constantly jabbering in your head
about what you're doing and the way you're doing it.
The two old guys up in the-
The two old guys up there,
tune out the boomers in your head.
(Rich laughing) Yeah.
And then you just have to,
you just have to surrender to the process,
and the process is going to be uncomfortable
a lot of the time.
The idea of flow state in athletics,
I think you can find it,
and you can find it in writing.
I have found it in writing where I'm like,
wow, this is amazing.
And I feel like all in,
I feel the flow.
But just because the experience feels good though,
doesn't mean the work will turn out,
like to be good.
Yeah, that's the illusion, right?
Yeah.
You think ah, it's going good.
It's going good.
But then, no back to the drawing board.
And sometimes-
Pick it up another day and look at it.
Right, and sometimes you bleed the words.
Every word costs like a pint of flesh or something.
And then you go back to read it.
You're like, wow, that was really good.
You hated the day.
It felt miserable.
When that happens to me though,
that just affirms that story,
that pain is the driver of quality.
Right.
Which is not a healthy-
No, so I think whether you're feeling doubt
about a project or feeling good about the project,
the key is to tune both those things out
to get the project done.
That's my only experience of it.
And it's something that I struggle with every day.
Like last week I was the one complaining
about my writing process.
It's not comfortable.
It's not necessarily always a fun job.
Yeah.
And you're doing it now with a newborn.
Like you have a new set of challenging complicated variables
that you didn't have to deal with before.
It's true, it's true, but at the same time,
I have more time to actually every day go and do a thing
'cause I haven't been on the road.
And so, but that hasn't led to prolific,
being super prolific yet, but-
Well I like that idea that Brad talks about
with self-awareness and I think it's related
to the piece you were speaking about
with respect to equanimity.
Like be the most present and self-aware
that you possibly can when you're in the midst
of doing the one thing that you're doing.
That's beautiful.
And that idea of equanimity made me think of that,
I don't know who said it, that quote,
that nature is never in a hurry,
but everything always gets done.
And I think about that and I'm like, I'm always in a hurry.
And most of the stuff I'm trying to do, doesn't get done.
(men laughing)
But I don't,
but looking at your life.
It's just a joke.
I don't find that to be completely untrue.
I know, but like that's the,
I'm like, why didn't I do that?
I didn't get anything done today.
It's, that's the self-defeating looping thought pattern
that's going on in my mind.
That if I don't make the time to meditate
and practice those mindfulness things that are so annoying
like that gets the best of me.
You definitely feel it like when I don't do that,
those little pieces, like the,
I'm not really having time to meditate too much,
but I have like an affirmation with Zoom every morning
after yoga.
If I get to yoga, if I can do it.
So it's like, you're right.
If you can start off and hit the first things
that you know are good for you,
then maybe you have a chance at finding balance that day.
Yeah, you're taking out an insurance policy
on having a better day.
Yeah.
But this idea of balance though like you're saying,
I think the whole inspiration for you, right,
I mean correct me if I'm wrong is,
it's okay to tackle this book that way.
'Cause it might just be,
the way you are now, Rich Roll,
this version of yourself,
that's your nature right now?
Doesn't mean that will be your nature forever.
It's definitely my nature.
And the idea is for me I think to be
in self-acceptance of that,
but also not do it in a self-destructive addictive way.
Like to get the best out of my ability to immerse myself
on a project and be focused without
the kind of downside aspects of it that I think
are a relic of history of alcoholism that I think
comes into play.
I think about that when I'm out riding my bike at PCH
and I see the surfers out there
or somebody out swimming,
and I'm like, I should be swimming.
Or I should be surfing.
And I can guarantee you if I was surfing,
I'd see a cyclist,
and I'd be like,
I really should be on my bike right now.
(men laughing)
You know what I mean?
Like there's, it's not a grass is greener thing,
it's more like wanting to do everything simultaneously
all the time and just being present for what you're doing
in the moment.
It's like living at the intersection of YOLO and FOMO.
(men laughing)
Yeah.
You don't want to be there.
How do those two intersect in the Venn diagram?
That'll be next week's Roll On.
Well the more YOLO, the less FOMO, right?
Right, but yet what you're saying is you have FOMO
for the YOLO you're not doing.
Yeah, that's true.
(Adam laughing)
Because there's always,
yeah there's always something else
that you're missing out on.
There's multiple YOLOs.
Yeah, in the extended YOLO universe,
there's infinite FOMOs.
Right, yes, yes, exactly.
(Rich laughing)
But when you think of YOLO,
you don't think of hunching over a computer
and typing a book.
Although when you think of FOMO,
you can definitely.
God that book is out.
Well, I could be out training and saying
oh my God, like, I really need to be getting on this.
Like I have anxiety,
because the book is not gonna write itself.
That kind of thing.
And these years don't come back to you.
They do not.
Did we accomplish anything productive
for the listeners in talking about that?
Well you know what I think?
I think the listeners are gonna be like,
wow, Rich is just up as fucked up as we are.
(men laughing)
There's hope.
There's hope for us all.
Yeah, there's hope.
Cool, so let's do a little bit of show and tell shall we?
Let's do it.
We got a little SriMu out here on the desk today,
and there's a reason for that.
Enjoy.
Here have some.
I bought-
Oh did you?
April.
Here slide this over.
Can you grab that?
Yes.
The reason that I'm doing a little show
and tell around it today is because SriMu has just.
So for those who are listening
who don't know what I'm talking about,
SriMu is my wife's plant-based cheese company.
It's really remarkable stuff that she's created.
There was a recent review.
Somebody said, "This cheese is absolutely lusty.
It's a whole new cheese planet."
I thought that was a great review.
But anyway, I'm bringing it up,
because it's a subscription model.
You order these cheese wheels.
They're, artisinal, like just next level,
the next evolution of cheese.
Like your favorite Camembert, Brie, like insane.
But the subscription box has traditionally been
like a large box that is,
can be pricey for certain people,
so they just launched a two wheel box,
which is much more affordable.
The two wheel flavor options are,
Julie always has these great names,
Awaken Magic,
which is Gold Alchemy and Elder,
or Awaken Heart
which is Bertie and Elder.
Gold Alchemy is sort of like a smoked Gouda infused
with smoke and turmeric.
The Elder is like a Brie.
The Bertie is like a Camembert with truffle in it.
They're insane.
But this two wheel box is 59 bucks plus shipping
for a subscription,
or $69 plus shipping for a one-time purchase.
And they're running a special,
Father's Day special,
which is why I'm bringing it up right now
where you can get 10% off any Awaken two wheel or Devoted,
which is their three-wheel box,
or Ritual, their four wheel box
if you order before or by June 11th.
So the orders will ship June 14th
and you use the coupon code FathersDay10 at checkout.
And that's what you do.
So Blake, can you pull this up?
The website is SriMu,
srimu.com/fathers-day,
and you can see the offering there.
But it's really remarkable stuff.
And I just wanted to shout out the Father's Day special,
because hardworking nurturing dads of the world could do
with a little bit of a plant-based luxury.
I purchased it,
the Mother's Day special version of that.
And it was a big hit.
It is a big hat.
Yeah, so Blake it's srimu.com/fathers-day.
Should pull up right there and you could see it.
It's that special URL.
So FathersDay10 at checkout for 10% off.
There you go.
Boom.
Happy Father's Day.
Look at that beautiful cheese, right?
This cheese is nuts.
A couple other show and tells things that I wanted to do.
My boy Simon Hill from the Plant Proof podcast, his book,
"The Proof is in the Plants" is out in Australia right now.
So for anybody who's in Aus, who's listening,
you should pick that up.
I think it was a number one bestseller
in the non-fiction category or something like that.
Like he's killing it out there.
Also, his podcast is fantastic.
I talk about it all the time.
If you're not listening to that.
You should check it out.
And the book is gonna be dropping in the US I think,
a while ago he said two months,
so maybe in July.
I'll keep you posted on that.
But I'm excited for that book to be available here
in the US.
Simon really knows his stuff.
He also has a really great affect in terms
of talking about nutrition and navigating the peccadilloes
of the online nutrition wars
in terms of his plant-based advocacies.
It's just that he's a beautiful guy.
He's ripped.
He's fantastic.
He's got a great restaurant in Bondi called Eden.
Eden Bondi.
So if you haven't eaten there next time you
find yourself in Bondi,
you have to go to Eden.
Dude, I might find myself there soon
'cause someone's got a passport.
That's right.
The baby got a passport.
Oh you got an Australian passport.
No, we got a US passport for the baby.
For the baby.
Oh, a US passport for the baby.
Yeah.
Who was I talking to though?
Somebody was telling me they just
got an Australian passport.
We're heading in that direction.
You gotta, you have to.
He had to get his passport first,
and then he'll be the first to get residency if he wanted
or get a passport if he wants.
Nick, can you get a passport for Australia?
And then I can go through the process too.
But I think.
Wow.
I don't know if I'll get a passport.
I can get residency.
I don't think I can get a passport, no.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Should we talk about The Spirited Man?
Let's talk about The Spirited Man.
Did you check this out?
I did.
I watched all the way through.
How many of 'em did you watch?
Blake pull that YouTube channel up.
I watched all the way through the Fourth Turning.
You did?
Yes.
The Fourth Turning was good.
Yeah the Fourth Turning has 800
and something thousand views.
That's the one.
So The Spirited Man is
a relatively brand new YouTube channel and video series
courtesy of Van Neistat,
who is the older brother of Casey Neistat.
Yes.
The OG in the YouTube space.
Casey and Van started out together.
Before YouTube even existed,
these guys were making videos together.
They both had a tenure with Tom Sachs, the fine artist.
You can see both of the Neistat brothers aesthetic reflected
in what Tom Sachs does.
And it's interesting, Van is,
I've known Casey for years.
He's been on the podcast a bunch of times.
Like he was on,
before he even became,
like he was a YouTuber,
but before he was a vlogger.
Like it's been a long time.
We should have Casey back on,
but I didn't know anything about Van.
And then out of the blue,
Van launches this YouTube channel.
I think like six or seven weeks ago.
He's already got 380,000 subscribers.
It's a series called "The Spirited Man."
Each video is its own short story,
stand alone curio like art pieces.
They're beautifully rendered,
well thought out, philosophical,
reflections on the human condition essentially.
Yes.
And I just love it.
And his particular Spirited Man.
Yes, exactly.
And your Spirited Man.
His own Sprited Man journey.
Yes.
They are so unique and original.
And I think that is in part,
because this is a guy who's not on social media.
I don't think he's a guy who watches YouTube.
Like he's coming to the platform with his own sensibility
that's uncorrupted by everything else that we kind of scroll
and see every single day.
So there's a purity to it that's really beautiful,
and I think is lending itself
to this skyrocketing popularity.
I mean in no time this guy has like made an imprint
on YouTube and I'm excited to see where this goes.
Everybody should check it out.
The Spirited Man on YouTube.
Yeah I got through "Are You Spirited?" actually,
now that I'm looking at it.
"Are You Spirited?"
Yeah so, and he's coming on the podcast on Wednesday.
Fantastic you get to even hear more about it.
So Yeah, I'm gonna break it,
I'm gonna break it down with him.
A couple-
Did you watch the one on run,
"Does Running Suck?"
I did not.
I don't need to know.
I know the answer to that,
but actually now that I'm doing Zone 2,
I actually quite like it.
You do?
Yeah.
Right.
But one thing that I got out of it was the reward
for good work is more work
which I love that, that phrase.
And the episode on the Fourth Turning is very interesting.
It kind of speaks to the moment in time
we're having right now.
He's basically does a, it's a book report.
He simplifies an argument without you having
to read the book.
But what I like about it is he goes for depth.
He goes for-
It's all about that.
It's all about like what's bubbling
beneath all of this madness that we have to contend with,
and within himself, which you can tell,
there's kind of like that simmering of not discontent,
but just like what does it all mean kind of thing.
But with that sometimes comes like a discontent
with the way,
in trying to figure out,
he talks a lot about repair.
He's a fix it.
Yeah, so there's a, there's a old soul kind of
out of step with time aspect of him because he wants
to fix everything and we live in a disposable culture.
So what does it mean to be a repairman
in the vernacular of the Fourth Turning, right?
As a Gen Z guy, who's very good at repairing things
when the kind of call to repair is an antiquated concept.
In a way,
although I wouldn't say this 'cause he's not like getting
into mindfulness or anything,
excuse me, sorry.
He's not getting into mindfulness at all, specifically yet.
But one thing that came to mind is it's almost like
the new version of Zen and the art
of motorcycle maintenance,
but that's a YouTube series.
Because he's getting into like the whole nature
of repair and the fact that he's called to do that
and why that's important to him.
Nothing is on the nose,
but in a way you get his worldview on it.
In a way that reminds me of that book.
But I haven't read that book in a long time
and it comes to me.
Well, he, in the "Fourth Turning" video,
you see when he's stacking the books
and you see all those books,
there was one book that's called
"The Soul of Repair" or something like that.
I forget what the name of it is,
but it's kind of a zen in the art
of motorcycle maintenance type of book.
I think it's more like a manual,
but I saw an interview with Van and he said in that book,
there is a passage in which it talks
about The Spirited Man.
It uses that phraseology.
Right, no, he says that in that video.
Yes, yes, yes.
So that became the concept upon which he built this.
He's like The Spirited Man,
what would The Spirited Man do?
And it's all in the third person.
He's like this Spirited Man,
the Spirited Man or the Spirited Woman.
But when you talk about a spirited horse,
it's usually someone that's like, hey,
the horse is like nudging the other horse or whatever.
But the connotation that I read into that is,
is somebody who is out of step with the typical culture.
Like he's seeing things other people aren't seeing.
Like the whole thing with like fixing the dishwasher,
and fixing the Toyota, grill.
It's like the universe is not correct in this
and I must correct it, or I can't rest easy.
Or you can't move on, yes.
And this is the,
this is the compulsion of The Spirited Man.
Which I love it.
And so I'm all for it.
I think it's an amazing.
Thank you for turning me on to it.
I'll be watching 'em all.
It's cool.
So we have that conversation coming up
to look forward to.
In the meantime, check it out and subscribe.
What do you got there?
I just want to show you this new contraption I got.
I knew it.
(Adam laughing)
You came in and you said, "I have a special show and tell,
should I surprise you or show you now?"
And I was like, "Surprise me,
but I think I already know what it is."
This particular Spirited Man swims in a mask.
You do.
For those on audio only,
you just donned a diving mask that looks like
it came from a different era.
I am a man out of step with my time.
You are.
The Spirited Man is not a fan of swimming goggles.
The Spirited Man uses a mask,
because thereby he could decide at one moment to dive
instead of swim.
Yeah, that's right.
What is that particular model of spirited mask?
Would you like a warranty for this mask?
I don't know.
'Cause it comes with one.
Aqua Lung.
It's the Aqua Lung Sphera,
and oddly enough-
This is your replacement mask.
This is the replacement mask
for the one that was lost.
But you see, I can breathe out of.
I can exhale out of my nose.
It is at least a little bit more streamlined
and goggle like.
That's my point.
So you're finding some middle ground.
I feel like this is diplomacy.
This particular spirited man's mask was created
as an open water swim goggle replacement.
No, I'm not kidding.
And then, but swimmers, scoff at masks, like yourself.
And so free divers had to embrace it for it to live.
And here it is.
And it's the new version.
It's got racing stripes.
Have you noticed that?
I haven't, no, I can't see that far.
Anyway.
But all right, but good man.
So I will relent.
A detente has been a achieved.
(Adam laughing) Detente, yes.
Wait.
In the Oslow talks.
(Adam laughing) The Oslow talks have been achieved.
Now that the mask is on the podcast,
I just thought the listeners would love to see that.
That's good.
The other thing that I found is not to,
listen, not everyone likes biographies
of long gone sports stars.
I'm not going to belabor the point.
I've been really enjoying this Duke Kahanamoku biography.
It's relatively recent.
It's not, it didn't come out on a big publisher,
it's University of Nebraska Press, but it's,
and it's really painstakingly kind of creates his life.
It's not like the most compelling read
for people who aren't interested in sports like that or his,
but I do think that if you love water sports,
Duke Kahanamoku was a three-time Olympian,
over four separate Olympiads.
His peak, he would have been,
would have been right when World War I happened.
So he didn't even get to go to his,
when he was his peak condition.
I didn't know that.
And I didn't know that it was four Olympiads.
So he was 21, 22 years old in 1912.
And that was his first Olympiad.
And he, and they competed in Antwerp,
and it was like, excuse me, a canal.
Like a drainage ditch.
It was freezing.
Like the water was like, they were shivering.
That's what it was like in 1912.
He set world records.
He won the 100, he won the 200, I believe,
and got a silver in the relay.
Then he went back eight years later
and defended his titles,
won a couple more golds.
And then he won a silver in the,
I think in the 100, in the third Olympiad.
In like '24.
Getting beat by Johnny Weissmuller.
Weismuller, right.
Yeah, so he was,
he was way past his prime at that point.
Right, he was in his 30s.
1916 would have been his peak.
1916 was gonna be his peak
and he didn't even get to compete because
of World War I.
And then 1920 was in,
that might've been Antwerp.
Yeah, 1912 was in Sweeden, excuse me.
In 1916 was in Antwerp and it was freezing.
And it was like in this, in Belgium,
and it had been decimated by World War I.
And so like these,
but this was at the beginning kind
of early, early days of Olympiad.
In 1912, he competed alongside Jim Thorpe.
Two guys, Jim Thorpe was the decathalete
and the greatest athlete of the first 50 years
of the 20th century.
It's been declared that by basically everybody.
Jim Thorpe and Duke both went to schools where they were not
allowed to speak their native languages.
Jim Thorpe is indigenous American.
Indigenous yeah.
And Duke is full blooded Hawaiian.
And so they had that connection
and they were kind of really heroes to America
at a time when-
Massive heroes.
At a time when racism was like off the charts.
It was like, you know, Jim Crow was just getting huge,
and it was the birth of the nation time and all of that.
And so here these two guys come and capture
the imagination of America at such a fraught time.
And, but his, he wasn't just a great,
the greatest swimmer of his era.
He was also the greatest surfer of his era.
Yeah, I know.
(Adam laughing)
I mean, he transcended sport, he became a cultural icon.
He did.
To this day it resonates all across the world.
It's unbelievable.
It's amazing they haven't made a movie,
like a movie of those two lives in tandem
and parallel of Thorpe and Duke.
That's what I'm saying.
Together.
Yeah, like these two guys,
but then if you look at just at Duke,
he got during the influenza epidemic,
he got influenza.
He did?
One of the swimmers that he used to compete with early on
died of it.
He could have died,
but an ex-girlfriend found him like at the YMCA in New York,
like coughing up a lung, bleeding,
and got him treatment.
Or maybe it was in Germany, excuse me, and saved him.
And so he got that.
There was an incident that was recalled in this book.
And when he was surfing in Newport Beach
'cause he lived here in California.
He was pursuing acting
and he was in a bunch of films.
And he was surfing.
He camped on the beach at Corona Del Mar,
and it was a 20 foot day or something crazy,
and a boat,
they saw a boat coming in that got capsized
and he went out three different times
on his surfboard and he saved seven people's lives.
Wow.
Like maybe more, maybe it was like 10 people.
On, like pulling 'em on,
'cause his surfboards weren't like today surfboards
they were a hundred pound plus pieces
of wood that he carved himself and shaped himself.
You can't imagine a more-
And he was a cultural icon at that time, right?
He already was, yes.
It would be as if Laird Hamilton was out there
pulling people out of it.
It's exactly that.
And TMZ would be swarming.
And it would be like a huge media.
If your life was saved by Laird Hamilton.
(Adam laughing)
Yeah, right.
That's exactly what it was.
So anyway, but-
I'm gonna check that out, legend.
He also had all sorts of money problems
and different issues,
so it's not like everything was a home run for him.
What was ultimately Hawaii's relationship to him
once he became big and like moved to the States?
Well, I mean, the reason he moved to the States
was because it was,
so that's a good question.
So what happened was he was,
he did the Olympics,
then he decided he'd go pro.
After a while he decided to go pro,
but he couldn't really get a stage show
off the ground swimming.
And so he came back and retained his amateur status.
But in the meantime,
he went to Hollywood to try to make movies.
He was there for a period of time, came back to Hawaii.
And for whatever reason,
they couldn't figure out a way to,
he couldn't figure out a business that he could catch on to
that would be successful.
He ends up like, they think they're doing them a solid,
hey come work at the city, in City Hall in Honolulu,
and basically they have him sweeping and mopping the floors.
Like he was,
like that's how he was treated.
So then his friends in LA said, come back here.
And he came back and worked and coached
at the LA Athletic Club and was here and worked
at the Beach Club by the beach here.
But he doesn't-
Was that Jonathan Club or one of those clubs.
The Beach Club, I think.
Where's that?
It's right next to the Jonathan Club,
yeah but one of those two.
And then he ends up back in Hawaii after all
and runs for sheriff and becomes the sheriff of Oahu.
Oh I didn't know that.
Yeah, he became the sheriff for Oahu for years.
But the reason I bring it up is because in this book
they reference that he's on "This is your Life."
(Adam laughing)
And I went and the episode is on YouTube.
So if you wanna have 30 minute,
kind of primer and see Duke,
and see his whole family and everything.
"This is your Life," that old TV show.
From what year was this?
Like, '62?
It's gotta be the 50s.
Oh that early, 50s.
Maybe it's the 60s.
I have to, I'd have to look again.
But the ads are hilarious.
It's really funny to see old television and it's fun.
All right, well we'll throw that link up
in the show notes,
and the book "Waterman" is by,
what's the author's name?
David Davis.
Yeah, so I think,
I mean, I'm thoroughly enjoying it,
but obviously I'm mystified by this guy's story.
It's just incredible.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah.
Why hasn't there been a movie about this guy?
It seems like,
it's like a "Chariots of Fire" kind of thing.
Yeah it could be if you did it with Thorpe
I think you'd wanna do a Thorpe.
I would love to do that.
Like a Duke and Thorpe kind of,
you see them over time.
Thorpe ends up an alcoholic and he died in a trailer.
I know.
Like, we really see,
one thing I'm getting from reading this is you really do see
how athletes that are at their peak and really
the top of their sports as young men,
how hard it is for them to kind of figure out the next act.
Which we know.
We've talked about that.
Right, yeah your life peaks at such an early age
and you have the adulation of the world.
Like how are you gonna top that?
How are you going to find meaning in something else?
It's like "Raging Bull" and Jake LaMotta
when he's staring in the mirror at the end,
and he's all fat and he owns that bar and he's just,
he's just dining out on past glory.
And it's also,
it's a trip to hate to see how Waikiki used to be,
and how like the estuaries were drained
and all those,
like it's also makes you kind of feel
for how did we develop this way and why.
And we didn't know.
We didn't care.
Is it a mixture of we didn't know,
we didn't care, probably.
Yeah.
Well the whole history of Hawaii is so fraught.
But it's not just there.
You can say the same thing.
Any colonized power,
like in Bali right now,
the main garbage dump is in the middle of the wetlands.
Who put the first garbage dump in the middle
of the wetlands in Bali?
Most likely, I would submit,
would be the Dutch did that when the Dutch
were the colonists in Indonesia.
So why?
Because there was no con, con,
people didn't know that Western culture, developer culture,
which was kind of part of the colonists game.
They weren't thinking about the relationship of wetlands
and estuaries to their-
No, no, it was we're here, we're planting our flag,
and we're gonna conquer this land, and settle.
It's muddy.
It's dead space.
You can't build on it.
You can't farm in it.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
Well, let's pivot to wins of the week.
Let's do it.
We've got a couple of good ones.
Yes.
First up we have Hellah Sidibe who just
completed a run across the entire United States.
Blake maybe you can pull up one of those articles.
This guy is so cool and inspirational.
He just seems like he's overflowing with positivity
and gratitude.
He's a former MLS soccer player who basically just was like
I'm gonna run across the country.
I think he's like a YouTuber too.
Just completed this.
Yeah he is a YouTuber, yeah.
This run,
and there was footage.
He was live streaming it yesterday.
And my friend Robbie Balenger, who also ran across America,
who's how I found out about Hellah
because Robbie's been really supporting him
over the course of this endeavor.
He flew out to the middle of the country,
I don't know, a couple of months ago,
and ran with them for a couple of days.
Showed up just outside New York City to run
the final leg with him.
And they're all sharing it on Instagram live and stuff.
And it was so cool because he had all,
it was like a parade processional,
as they always danced into the city.
Mm, amazing, amazing.
He was sponsored by Jim Shark.
And Jim shark had this giant like topless bus
where they were like pumping hip hop music.
And it was like a party going on.
And he was just like this cheerleader,
with a big smile on his face and just positive energy
for miles as they made it into the city.
It was really cool to watch.
I called Robbie right after,
right after it,
just to get his low down.
And he's like, you gotta meet this guy.
He's so great.
Super cool.
And what was also cool,
speaking of Van Neistat and The Spirited Man,
Casey showed up to document that final leg too.
He was shooting all kinds of footage,
so we'll see what comes out of that.
That will be a good episode.
But it was cool to see those two guys
both friends of the podcast, both friends in general,
there to help support like this amazing human
do something cool and extraordinary.
And then at the finish line,
it was being broadcast on on Hellah's Instagram live,
but the sound went out,
so you couldn't hear what was going on.
Yeah, I had that same problem.
But when I talked to Robbie, he said,
I told him, I was like, we couldn't,
nobody could hear what was happening.
And he's like, well, he proposed to his girlfriend.
Oh my God.
Right in Manhattan at the conclusion
of this 3,000 mile run,
which I thought was pretty cool.
Yeah.
It'd be super harsh for her to have said no.
Yeah, no, yeah no.
(men laughing)
That was obviously not gonna happen.
I don't think that was gonna happen.
You know what I loved about the finish was he sprints
to the finish then he leaps in the air.
I mean, he's been running-
Well it was like a party going into the city.
It wasn't like, they weren't like hammering.
But he's been running every day for like 40 mile days.
Also on top of the cross country run,
he has some crazy run streak going on.
Right, four years.
I think for like the last four years,
he hasn't missed a day of running.
So for him it ain't nothing but a thing.
Apparently, he's the first black man to do
the cross country run in America.
Is that right?
I didn't know that.
That's what he, that's what he said,
and it's been written up that way, so yeah.
Wow, cool.
I gotta get this guy on the show.
You do?
Yeah, gotta make that happen.
So congrats Hellah.
Congrats Hellah.
Everybody should follow him on Instagram.
He's hellahgood9, hellahgood9.
That's his website up there that Blake pulled up,
hellagood.com.
What a stud.
Mad respect.
And can't wait to find a way to sit down with you
and hear all about this crazy adventure.
Awesome.
Should we talk about the greatest showdown
in the history of track and field that happened last week?
(Adam laughing)
Let's talk about it.
Malcolm Gladwell versus Chris Chavez.
Did you watch it?
I did.
It was pretty impressive.
I mean, Gladwell is very, very impressive.
It's so funny.
I love everything about this.
I'm so here for it.
Basically for those that aren't familiar,
Chris Chavez, who I've never met,
but I feel like as an internet friend of mine.
He writes for a Sports Illustrated.
He covers track and field and marathons and the Olympics
for that publication.
He's also a part of Citius Mag where he,
I don't know if he blogs there,
but he does a podcast.
So he's a podcast host.
He's a announcer.
He was also at this track meet like announcing other races.
He's kind of just a man about town in terms
of covering track and field and marathoning
and the Olympics,
running in the Olympics.
Young guy, 27.
At some point,
I don't know how the Genesis of this whole thing,
but Chris challenged Malcolm,
or Malcolm, I don't know who challenged who?
I thought it was Chris challenged Malcolm, but-
Yeah, I think Chris challenged Malcolm
to run a mile,
to see who could run the fastest mile.
Chris, 27.
Malcolm Gladwell, 58.
He calls himself The Skinny Canadian.
He is skinny.
Like I was very shocked how like-
He's very skinny, very skinny.
His legs too.
But kind of under appreciated in terms
of his running capability.
Oh my goodness.
He's a very good runner.
And he trains really hard.
Like I know plenty of runners
in New York City who will tell you like,
oh he's down at the track on the Lower East Side
all the time.
You can find him out there and he hits it really hard.
So even though he's 58,
he comes from a track and field background.
He's an excellent runner in high school.
And I think he ran in college too
and has stayed competitive.
I don't think he's raced in a couple of years.
So this was gonna be the first race in a while.
And the lead up to this was so delicious,
because there was a lot of smack talking back and forth.
Chris would, Chris was trying to pump people up.
And he said at one point,
"My mother is so confused when I'm racing an old man."
And then Malcolm said,
"I'm pretty sure I'm older than your mom,"
(men laughing)
which is probably true.
And I can tell you from friends that I have,
that are excellent runners who know Malcolm,
I've never met Malcolm.
But the word on the street is that Malcolm Gladwell
is a world-class sandbagger.
Like, he's the guy,
he'll always tell you, oh I didn't sleep,
or I'm like, I don't have it today.
Like he'll always downplay everything.
And then he'll just own you.
Like, that's his MO right.
(Adam laughing)
I love that.
So you come in, you set the expectation low,
and you create a situation in which you can over-deliver.
It's funny,
'cause even the race started out that way.
Like you saw him, like you saw him like drift to the back,
like maybe to get out of Chris's view
or something like that.
Right, yeah.
And then he just tracked him down.
So the whole thing going into this was I'm old.
Like I'm decra,
like just sandbagging all the way, right?
And then when you watched the mile,
which took place in New York City.
It was part of a legitimate meet,
called the New York City Qualifier where a bunch
of track and field athletes were trying
to make Olympic trials qualifying times.
And it wasn't just Chris and Malcolm.
It was a field of legitimate runners.
They had a rabbit,
they had a bunch of elite athletes running.
The one from the Whoop.
The person who works at Whoop, won the thing.
The woman.
Does she work at whoop?
I think so.
I think she's with Tracksmith.
Oh Tracksmith, oh Tracksmith.
Yeah she's with Tracksmith.
Malcolm's also with Tracksmith I believe.
He-
She was great.
She won the whole thing.
Man and Woman.
She crushed it.
Who's all, what's her name?
I'm blanking on her name right now,
but her sister is also
an exceptional track and field athlete.
In any event,
yeah Malcolm goes out, Chris takes it out.
I think they both had aspirations or at least Chris publicly
had aspirations of trying to break five minutes
in this mile.
So Chris takes it out.
They have a rabbit out there who's holding five minute pace.
Chris is kind of sitting right behind him
but Malcolm dropped way back.
So for the first half of the race,
he was kind of in no man's land way behind.
And then he just picked up the pace and very slowly,
but legitimately worked his up the field
and just passed Chris like he was standing still
and crushed him.
Totally, unbelievable.
Just crushed him.
They were both quite shy of breaking five.
Malcolm ran 5:15 and Chris ran 5:23.
Chris was a good sport about the whole thing.
But I just loved that Malcolm owned him in that way.
Me too.
At 58 years of old, of age.
Izzy Seidel is her name.
Izzy Seidel, yeah.
So Molly Seidel is Izzy's sister.
And then Izzy, I think works at Tracksmith.
I don't know if she's trying to get to the Olympics or not,
but she looked great.
She was under five minutes.
Yeah, she ran like 4:54 or something.
And she was like,
she was like the smoothest.
Like it looked like it didn't even,
it didn't even phase her.
Right, she's a powerhouse.
Oh my goodness.
For sure.
Anyway, it was super fun to watch.
The YouTube of the whole thing,
well the whole track meet is on YouTube,
but you can fast forward and watch the race of these guys.
It was really fun to see that.
And that was a true,
much like the Des Linden 50K world record.
It was a kind of an internet experience
where the whole internet kind of tuned in to see
how this was gonna go down.
It was great.
And I think,
Malcolm talks about this himself quite a bit.
Like how do you make people more interested in sport?
Like, he's talked about how in triathlon,
they should put the swimming last.
Like if they wanna make it hard.
Yeah, right.
Like wear 'em out and then make 'em swim
and see who survives that.
Wouldn't that be more interesting?
You'd have some dead people.
In his classic hot take,
Yeah, we might have problems.
But in his classic like contrarian hot take perspective,
I think it is, and this race was an example,
of how to get people who perhaps aren't super dialed in
and interested in track and field.
Like I don't watch track and field meets.
No.
But I watched this, right?
Like more of this please.
And then perhaps we can all get a little bit more excited
about this stuff.
So Blake just pulled up the race.
Is this it?
No, I think it's at like 40.
Yeah, it's 45 minutes.
45 minutes in or something, 48.
I understand what you're saying,
but I think I'd rather watch Usain Bolt.
Listen, I'm not saying at the cost
of true track and field.
Oh you're saying, instead of Usain Bolt.
But I'm saying in addition to that,
I think it's cool to play with the format a little bit.
I do too.
Like they're doing this with swimming.
They have these pro circuit meets now
where they're trying different events and sprint events
and things that like get the audience,
a typical audience that isn't steeped
in the swimming culture to get interested about this stuff.
And I feel like this accomplished that
and in a really kind of great format.
Yeah like when would you ever watch this particular event?
Like there's at least,
like, this is not like-
No, but I was like, I was like in my car.
I was in the passenger seat in my car when it was going,
I was like, I have to watch.
I have to like, we have to pull over or you have
to like let me see what is happening right now.
Like, look at him.
He's got the compression socks on.
Yeah, he's got, he's in spikes too.
Everybody, everybody in their-
Not everybody was in spikes.
Everybody's in their twenties.
But not everyone was in spikes.
Isn't that interesting?
I think Chris is too.
Chris is in spikes.
Spikes was an interesting choice.
So he doesn't do road.
He mostly does track right?
He's a track guy,
and he's super into it.
Like he's on, reading the forums,
and he knows everything that's going on in track and field.
But I just thought it was pretty great
that at 58.
Pretty impressive.
5:15 at 58.
Good for him.
Unbelievable.
Steve Magness tweeted, "Experienced defeats youth
in the running journalist slash influencer mile."
They both are kind of small.
Like Chris is about the same size.
Well Chris is more built.
Well he's the same size.
Like he's got a little more kind of bulk on him.
I mean Malcolm has the classic runner,
super skinny physique.
Yeah, hook how easy they're going,
but it's like-
I know it looks like they're running slow.
It's a five minute pace.
I know it's a five minute pace.
Look how easy that is for them.
I know it's crazy.
And lots of women in there mixing it up who-
Dominated by a woman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah for sure.
She won by like 20 meters or something like that.
But look at Malcolm just sits behind Chavez.
He's just gonna let,
he's boat biding his time.
That's the experience.
You can create the perception
that Chris was going to run away with it.
Yes.
It does look like they're running slow,
doesn't it?
It's crazy.
It does.
There's an obstacle illusion afoot.
Yeah, anyway, good times.
I loved it.
In the wake of it,
Chris being a good sport tweeted,
"Got my kicked in the mile by Gladwell."
And then Malcolm responds to that by saying,
"Happy to try again when you're my age and I'm 87."
Yeah, 'cause Chris right away wanted a rematch.
Yeah.
We'll do it when you're my age.
We'll try that.
That's hilarious.
Like I said, more of this, I think it's fun.
I don't think that it,
there's any negative impact to the greater track
and field universe by doing stuff like this
from time to time.
No, I don't see.
No, not at all.
Like, is that, is that what someone's worried about?
No, I just think like there is a vein of thought
that is oriented around respect for traditional,
the traditional way of doing it.
Okay.
This is track and field.
Like how dare you spoil or corrupt our little universe
with some stunt.
With some intramural thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's interesting,
Phil Mickelson who won a major in the PGA,
he tried that when there was no golf going on.
Didn't he have like put together,
he and Tiger put together like matches?
He was, one was with Peyton Manning,
the other one was with Tom Brady or something.
There's Seidel, look at her crush it.
Look at her.
4:50, yeah 4:54.
4:55
4:55.
Let's give her 4:54.
Let's give her 4:54.67.
Yeah, she wins by six seconds.
It's crazy.
I know.
Anyway, all right.
Let's do some listener questions.
All right, let's do it.
Actually, Malcolm's gonna cross here.
Should we, here he comes.
Look at him.
He worked for it.
He did.
We are now catering to a YouTube audience
that's watching with us.
We are.
I don't know if that-
Jason you to might have to monkey with this.
What we should be doing?
Anyway cool.
Listener questions, let's do it.
So this is,
I believe it's Sierra from Kalamazoo, Michigan.
Hey, Rich and Adam.
My name is Sierra.
I'm 23 years old and I'm currently living
and going to school in Kalamazoo, Michigan.
I struggled a lot with my mental health
from a very young age.
At about 12,
I was diagnosed with clinical depression, anxiety,
and I struggled for a long time.
When I got to undergrad,
I was stable in my mental health,
but I realized how bad my physical health was.
I've since lost 50 pounds,
signed up for my first marathon this summer,
and just hit one year of being completely plant-based.
Right now, I have a question regarding my life as it is now.
I'm currently struggling with the complex
of quote doing it all.
I work about 35 hours a week in retail to pay my bills.
I'm a full-time student,
and a teaching assistant at the school.
I dedicate at least two hours a day
to practicing my craft of clarinet playing.
And I exercise six days a week.
I'm often looked up to as a leader
in my role in retail and at the school.
I'm often there to support other people,
but I am living alone and halfway across the country
from my family.
I can't remember the last time I had a day to do nothing
and I'm loving what I'm doing,
but at the same time,
super exhausted.
Any and all advice would be welcome.
And thanks.
Shout out to Sierra in Michigan.
I know.
Go blue.
You're killing it.
It's such a good question.
I love this question and I think it's really relevant
to what we were talking about earlier,
about balance.
I agree.
It's super related to that.
That's why I put that in here.
Good for you, curating experience.
See what I'm doing?
Based on a theme.
I'm linking.
I'm linking the segments.
You are, you are.
I already told you your job is secure.
(Adam laughing)
Have you seen my swim mask?
Yeah, I have.
I have and I didn't,
Did I make fun of you?
No, I did not.
(Adam laughing)
I said we reached a detente in the Oslo talks.
Sierra, great question.
I think this is a common predicament for many.
The first thought that comes to mind
is something I learned in sobriety,
which is this idea of the road is always getting narrower.
So you start out, you have these mental health struggles.
You seem to get on top of that.
You then set your sights on your physical health.
You've lose all this weight.
You run a marathon.
It's like I got it together.
But the road continues to narrow
and you face new challenges that force you
to confront yourself in deeper ways.
Like you've done this heavy lifting in these other areas
and now this other stuff is showing up.
And I think what you're experiencing
is really common to a lot of people.
Again, it's related to our conversation about balance,
very much rooted in that.
And I think based upon what you're saying,
that your life is not,
the way you're living your life right now is not sustainable
in the longterm.
I think you're doing what you need to survive at the moment,
and pursue your goals and really develop
your craft and your talent and your passion.
And I think it's super laudable,
like mad respect for everything that you've taken on.
Everything that you're shouldering right now
to make all of this happen.
And I think at 23, you're young,
you can handle it for now,
but you have taken on a lot.
And I think, you're gonna need to really,
and it sounds like you're already doing this,
like figure out a way to pursue this path
in a more sustainable way.
And I suspect just based upon
the way you've described yourself
that you're somebody who has a predisposition
to over deliver in everything that you do.
Do you get that sense, Adam?
No doubt.
Yeah, she's crushing it, right?
Like she's showing up and killing it
in all these different areas.
But I think over time when you are that kind of person
and you shoulder that kind of responsibility
and you create those expectations with other people
that you're engaged with,
it's going to drain the joy out of everything
that you're doing and it will inevitably lead to burnout.
So that's the first thing.
I also, and tell me what you think Adam,
I also smell a little hint of co-dependence in this.
This idea that Sierra is over-giving of herself
to meet everyone else's needs.
Like she's, she,
everybody in the retail job loves her,
and she's a TA,
so she's there for her students.
She's showing up for all these other people at the cost
of her own wellbeing, which is secondary.
So she goes home at night, completely depleted and lonely,
because she's living alone.
So I think the first thing is figuring out how to-
Maybe 'cause she can't do that for her family
'cause they're far away.
So it's kind of a sub for that.
Right, well I'd be interested in what
the family dynamic is.
Like, so is she somebody who in her rearing
was somebody who showed up for other people
in her family in the same way that she's doing this
for her students and then her retail job?
I would suspect that that's likely.
Highly likely.
Yeah, yeah, right.
So here she is alone.
Doesn't have the family support
and doesn't have that outlet for showing up
for other people as she did in the house growing up
and she's doing it in this other way.
So I think, I think Sierra,
you need to flip the script
and first understand and accept
that you can't be everything to everybody all the time.
And as a people pleaser myself, I get it.
But the question really should be,
how do you please yourself?
And by please yourself,
I don't mean that in an indulgent or selfish way,
but really what do you need to make sure
that your needs are being taken care of
so that you're fit, adequately fit,
to show up for these other people and in all
of these other areas of your life.
There's a great Marcus Aurelius quote
that I think is relevant to this.
He said, "I have often wondered how it is
that every man loves himself more than all the rest of men,
but yet sets less value on his own opinion
of himself than on the opinion of others."
So again, this is a bit of a projection Sierra,
because I don't know you,
but it sounds like you are somebody who does concern herself
with the opinion of the people in your retail job
and these students that you're TA,
like all these different jobs that you have
and you're coming last in this.
And as a result you're suffering.
So I think you need to get really clear
on what your main priorities are first and foremost,
figure out a way so that you can focus on that
and learn to be okay with imperfection in your other areas,
especially in regards to these less important facets
of your life.
Like your re,
like I presume that you're not pursuing a career in retail,
you're trying to become
this unbelievable clarinet performer.
So how can you, and it's tough,
like these are real life problems.
You gotta pay your bills, you're working two jobs,
you're a full-time student.
Like this is not an easy equation to solve,
so the last thing I wanna do is come across
as like pithy with all of this, because it's very difficult.
But I do you think a process or a strategy
for tackling this is to,
A, do an honest inventory of everything that you do.
Literally get a notepad or a Moleskine and journal
how you spend your time in 15 minute increments.
Do that over for a week,
and I think you'll get an objective picture
on how you're actually spending your time.
There probably will be surprising areas
where you're spending more time doing something
than you originally thought that you were.
That will give you a launchpad to then evaluate what it is
that you could possibly let go of
or deescalate and other areas of your life
that are not getting the adequate amount of attention.
And give you a roadmap for how you could
perhaps simplify your life.
Like if your life is so crowded and so complicated
that you're going from one thing to the next thing
to the next thing, to the next thing,
never really having the bandwidth to invest
in any self care whatsoever.
And then just coming home and crashing.
That's not a great life plan.
And as somebody who's trying to cultivate a creative talent,
you need that nurturing time in order to really connect
with the best of what you have to offer
with respect to this art form that you're pursuing.
You just can't succeed in life.
You can't succeed in your goals unless you take care
of yourself first and you actually can't adequately
take care of all these other people that you're trying
to take care of right now,
unless you take care of yourself first.
So approach it,
not from the perspective of that being indulgent or selfish,
but actually necessary in terms of you optimizing
the opportunity that you have right now
to step into becoming this artist.
A hundred percent.
What do you think?
I think you nailed it.
I think prioritizing where you can find time
for yourself is gonna be key to,
'cause it's a long haul to become great at and master
a craft like the clarinet
and you need to,
you can't afford to burn out now.
And a lot of musicians do because it's so competitive.
And it's sometimes,
the satisfaction you get of doing a good job at a retail job
is more readily,
it comes to you easier.
Right, you'll get the validation immediately.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or as a leader in whatever.
That's why a lot of people take certain jobs
'cause they're elevated as leaders right away.
And leadership can be fulfilling,
'cause you're helping people achieve something.
She's on the grind though.
It reminds me of law school.
Like when you're that age, you can do it.
And you could do it for a while.
You could do it,
like I couldn't do that now.
I would collapse,
but when you're 23, you're robust, you can handle it.
But I just think it's a time in your life where you
have an opportunity to develop healthier life skills
around these things.
I agree.
And you really need to protect
what's most important to you.
A hundred percent.
Cool.
Good luck, Sierra.
Good luck.
Thank you for the question.
All right.
Let's go up towards the Bay Area.
This person recorded their question on their own mic.
You don't have to do that people.
Wow.
I know,
well he did record it on our system,
on our phone line, but then he got cut off.
And so now I'm, I am-
Oh he like sent an audio file or something.
He said he sent the audio file.
You emailed this to me.
And so now I'm finding it and it's coming your way.
Hey Rich.
This is Kevin from San Francisco Bay Area.
I'm a fan of the gospel that you're spreading,
and I really appreciate your recent episode
with Matthew Walker on sleep.
I have a question that I think you are uniquely
positioned to help answer.
See sometimes I'll do an intensive workout
at around noonish.
I'll run, bike, swim, or do some at-home P90X,
which all burn a lot of calories.
So immediately after my workout,
I'll have a high calorie plant-based recovery smoothie,
like one of the recipes in The Plantpower Way.
And then a little later I'll eat some other foods
and meals like a big bowl of oatmeal
and later another huge bowl of salad for dinner.
And many times I'll also sneak in a large veggie smoothie.
I try to focus on consuming as much leafy greens
and micronutrients as possible while also trying
to get in my needed macros,
but also not trying to overdo my macros too much
as I tend to gain weight pretty easily.
However, sometimes it seems like I'm
not consuming enough calories,
because once it gets time for bed,
I'll feel pretty full mostly because of all the greens
that I've consumed.
But then over time while I'm in bed,
my body will feel light, jittery, and hungry
to the point that I'll need to get out of bed
and go to the kitchen and eat something more.
Only now that I've eaten a plant-based late night snack
the fiber in that vegan snack starts to turn
in my digestive system, including smoothies,
which prevents me from further being able to fall asleep.
It's kind of this catch 22 scenario.
Anyway, thank you Rich.
Awesome story of my life, Kevin.
Story of my life.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause I-
This is-
'Cause I immediately thought he's just not
eating enough calories.
Well, I think that's a huge part of it.
Like he's just eating too much salad and oatmeal.
You burn through that stuff.
Yeah. I think that, I think these under, I think he's,
because he was obese and he lost all this weight
and he's trying to be first of all
thank you for your question, Kevin.
I love this question,
because he's formerly obese and he's trying
to be really diligent about his nutrition going forward
and is so cautious and afraid of putting on weight,
because of that past experience,
that he's under fueling himself,
because he's terrified of putting on weight.
But what he's doing is he is not getting enough calories
and that's creating the agitation
that's leading to the sleep problem.
It's an interesting thing.
I've experienced this myself and all,
the thing is,
all the science supports not eating right before bed.
You're not supposed to eat right before you go to bed.
You're supposed to eat hours before.
If I eat like three hours before bedtime
and then I go to bed,
inevitably I will either be unable to fall asleep
or I'll wake up like two or three hours later,
and I'd have to go into the kitchen and eat more.
Really?
All the time.
So that has led to an unhealthy habit
of eating close to my bedtime,
which isn't great,
because then as your body is digesting the food,
when it's done with that digestive process,
you end up waking up.
Like you wake up at like 3:00, right?
I've played with this so many different ways.
So I feel you, Kevin.
I relate to this.
I'm also,
I wasn't formerly obese.
I was heavier, but I'm conscious of my caloric intake.
So I tend to eat light during the day
and then have a larger dinner.
But I've had that same experience
of lying in bed awake, hungry, unable to asleep.
All this stuff.
I don't have a magic bullet for this,
but two things.
One is the thing we already mentioned
which is I think that you really are under fueled,
and that sense of fullness isn't due
to you meeting your caloric needs.
It's because you're eating this super fibrous.
Very bloaty stuff.
Bloaty stuff that gives you the sensation
of being full and is great because
it will prevent you from overeating,
and it basically turns off that appetite mechanism.
But all those leafy greens,
all of that fiber,
very high in the micronutrients
and the phytochemicals and all those things that you want,
but at the same time,
if you're working out as hard as you're working out,
like you got to put food in your system.
Yeah, smoothies aren't good enough.
And when you're not eating meat and dairy,
which tend to be incredibly calorically dense foods,
this is a common thing with people who go plant-based.
They're like, I'm always hungry.
And it's like, well you used
to eat like burgers and milkshakes,
and now you're eating salads and quinoa.
Like, you're gonna have to eat a lot more
than you're used to eating.
And because if you're eating it in a whole food way,
like there is all that extra fiber,
so you'll feel full,
but you're actually not getting sufficient calories.
And your body is like,
I'm trying to repair myself.
Like I'm, the agitation like that,
that kind of shakiness that you get is your body trying
to tell you that you need to eat more.
The other thing that I think it could be helpful for you
is that I found,
and this is purely anecdotal,
but I've found personally that when I eat more
throughout the day,
that's helpful.
So with this pension that I have for eating light
throughout the day,
sometimes that will lead to this problem at night,
even if I eat a big dinner.
But when I'm eating,
when I'm not like doing an intermittent fast or whatever,
and I'm eating throughout the day and I eat a decent lunch
and all of that,
then I can eat a decent dinner and I'll find myself less
in less of a struggle to go to sleep.
So larger portions eaten consistently and earlier
throughout the day will I think help ameliorate that.
Yeah, because what you're talking about here
is working out really hard and then having a smoothie,
then having a bowl of oatmeal, and a salad.
Like to me, like that's just not enough food.
I think that's right.
Yeah 'cause I'll have oatmeal in the morning before,
even before a run or like an hour or so before I swim.
Right he didn't talk about anything
that he eats before noon,
so I don't know if he's not eating before noon
or he's eating a breakfast that he
just didn't tell us about.
Who knows?
But like I'm not telling anyone what to eat.
I'm not in that business,
but pasta is a very filling thing
that could be good if you need carbs.
I know it's.
Well.
I don't know how controversial it is to eat pasta.
Pasta is not,
pasta wouldn't be the first thing that I recommend.
Pasta is very effective.
If you eat that right before you go to bed, you'll pass out.
'Cause all the blood goes to your belly
to digest this food,
you'll you wake up at three o'clock in the morning.
Don't eat pasta.
So I don't know if it's,
it will do the trick in terms of getting you to fall asleep.
Not sure that's the best practice,
but perhaps get over this fear of macros
and start eating complex carbohydrates that are satiating.
You can eat potatoes, you can eat sweet potatoes,
you can eat long grain rice.
Like there's plenty of things that you could be eating.
Curries, beans and rice.
Tons of beans.
I eat gigantic, gigantic bowls of beans and rice.
My kids still like, we'll get plates,
we go to the dinner table,
they have their normal plates out and I'll go
and I'll get the giant like salad bowl.
And then I put my dinner in that and they laugh every time,
but I just feel like I gotta eat more.
Eat avocados.
Like that's, Tom Brady eats, drinks avocados.
You can eat avocados.
Right and I think there is a little bit
of a block here,
because of that fear of gaining weight.
And maybe you need to,
in letting go of that,
be okay with putting on a little bit of weight
as you figure this out for yourself,
because what you wanna do is have the weight come off
the right way,
so it stays off well.
But if you're constantly starving and not sleeping well,
because you're afraid of putting on weight,
you're not going to sustain this anyway.
No.
You're gonna end up lapsing back
into some unhealthy habits.
Alexey Molchanov once told me years ago.
He's a great free diver, world record holder.
Said, "It's not the number that on the scale,
it's okay to have a bigger number, if you're fit."
Fitness, fitness, fitness.
Fitness nd how you feel.
And the number on the scale are two separate things,
you don't have to.
They don't mean the same thing.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, good point.
Final thought for Kevin is to,
and he didn't talk about this at all,
which I think he,
which is instructive that he didn't bring it up.
But I'm curious about what his pre sleep routine is.
Like perhaps there's some work that you could do
around setting yourself up for a good night of sleep.
Like are you having a magnesium tea at night?
Are you avoiding those screens?
Do you take a bath?
Maybe take a warm bath,
like an hour before you go to bed.
Do an evening meditation.
Listen to, get the Calm app out.
Listen to a sleep story.
Like part of this might also be induced by anxiety.
Like what part of this is more of a mental emotional thing,
And what part of it is actually a physiological response
to his food intake?
And if all else fails,
listen to "Roll On."
You'll go right out.
Right, get a tent, cold air in the room, get a face mask,
a gravity blanket.
The world is your oyster Kevin.
And David Attenborough.
He puts me right to sleep.
There you go.
Yeah, there's certain people, right?
Nature sounds, whatever does it for you.
Cool.
But hey, thanks for the question.
I thought that was helpful.
Thank you, Kevin.
Yeah, and thanks for the great recording.
That's right.
His own mic.
I know.
Should we require that everybody have their own mic now?
No, it makes my job a lot harder.
Please don't.
All right, the last one is a fun one
from a friend in Columbus.
Hey Rich and Adam,
this has Ben calling from Columbus, Ohio.
I recently packed up my things, left my job,
and decided to go on a road trip out west for four months.
I got two questions for you guys.
One, what book would you bring on a road trip for yourself?
And secondly,
Adam I know you're looking for running questions,
so I've been a road runner my whole life
and I'm excited to hit the trail.
What tips do you have for me to transition from pavement
to trail running?
Thanks.
Adam, what do you think the odds are
that Ben's four month trip turns into a one year trip?
High.
I think it's high.
Yeah.
I hope so.
I hope I-
Extend it, right?
Huh?
Extend it.
Does Ben seem young to you?
I'm jealous.
Or is Ben mid-career?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
He didn't, he didn't leave his age, right?
No.
Well, he had a job,
so he's not like just graduating from college
or something like that.
I feel like it's the first job out of college though.
I think so.
First or second.
I pin him at maybe 24, 25.
Okay, mid- 20s, yeah.
I hope we're not way off on that.
No.
I suspect mid twenties,
but thanks for the question, Ben.
I am jealous.
That sounds like such a cool opportunity
to just hit the road four months.
The world is your oyster.
Like yes, me too.|
You know what I mean?
When life was simple, Adam.
Quit Job, pack car.
When life was simple.
Hey, we had our run.
I know we did, right?
Yes.
I'm happy where I'm at.
I'm good.
It's okay.
I'm sorry, Ben.
We're back to ourselves.
Yeah.
(men laughing)
Books, books.
You can't go on a four month road trip.
This lighting out on the frontier in a journey
of self-discovery.
Head west.
Without reading "On the Road" by Jack Kerouac.
Are you even allowed to go on a four month road trip
as a young man?
Without "On the Road?"
Without having read "On the Road?"
I mean "On the Road" is seminal book for me,
I've probably read it 10 times.
I didn't include that on my list since you had first,
you had first dibs.
It's such a Gen X,
It's a Gen X, Boomer referral though, is it not?
It is.
It might be, it may,
has that book been canceled?
Can we check the cancellation file?
(Rich laughing)
I think it's okay still.
Who's in charge of the cancellation vault?
I think that one's all right.
I think it is too.
Yeah.
So I would recommend that, but you,
sorry I was like,
you were about to say something else.
No, I think it's a great question.
I think it's a two parter, go for it.
You have a few books down here.
Right, well I'm just thinking,
okay Ben,
what's going on in Ben's life that he decided
to quit his job,
pack everything up and like head out on the road.
Well obviously, it feels like an inflection point
where he wants to go inward a little bit
and figure out what the next thing is.
Or maybe connect a little bit more deeply
with who he is.
And so one of the books that you would recommend somebody
who's playing around with that,
"On the Road,"
because you're on the road.
Right?
Why not "A Man's Search for Meaning" by Viktor Frankl.
Tops everybody's list who's grappling
with these ideas, I think.
And one of my favorites also,
"Autobiography of a Yogi" by Paramahansa Yogananda.
I wanted to like that one.
And I couldn't get through it.
Couldn't get behind it?
Too magical.
Too crazy.
I think my problem with it
is every chapter ended well.
It's very dense.
Because his life was,
he was a magnificent human being.
I'm very, a big fan of Paramahansa Yogananda.
I just didn't get through the entire autobiography.
I think it's just a cool book to expand
your sense of possibility
and develop some appreciation for the mystical.
So my, you wanna hear a Paramahansa Yogananda story?
I do.
Before we get into finish this question.
So during, I think it was during the LA Yoga days,
when we first started LA Yoga magazine,
I set up a meeting with the head
of the Self-Realization Fellowship at the time.
I think it was number, maybe it was number two.
And their headquarters are in Mount Washington
in Los Angeles,
which was the original house,
the original estate before any of the others.
That's where he set, Paramahansa Yogananda, set up shop.
And we were supposed to have our meeting in the boardroom
which has like all these really cool artifacts and stuff.
And I was really excited to sit there
and have this conversation,
but we got booted.
And I was a little disappointed, but he goes,
let's sit by the fireplace.
And the guy wasn't particularly warm or anything,
or like memorable,
but he said a lot of people say after,
he used to spend every evening down here having tea
by the fireplace every evening
and had whoever guests came through,
that's where he'd spend his time.
And they say you,
people can feel his presence sometimes.
And at the time,
I wasn't particularly a huge Paramahansa Yogananda guy
'cause he was merging his worldview with Jesus,
and trying to make yoga more palatable by using Christianity
as some sort of a Trojan horse say,
or not even a Trojan,
that's a disrespectful way of putting it.
But to show the, how they fit together.
And so I was like pretty new to that world,
had my interview with him.
Like I said, he was not super impressed with me.
I didn't really like him that much.
(Rich laughing)
But then we finished the interview fine.
And I get up, and walking out the door,
and I'm like physically high,
like I'm floating out of my body kind of high.
Like I'm just like, light headed.
Wow.
Like my, all my energy,
exact flow state kind of stuff.
Like seriously, like time slowed down.
I felt it a few times in my life,
but this was very profound.
Wow.
And not, no drugs, no nothing.
Like it felt like the coming on of a psychedelic trip
without taking any drugs.
That's what it felt like.
So what do you make of that?
Yogananda.
Yeah.
Yeah, no question.
That's a trip, man.
Isn't that cool?
That is a trip.
So for people that don't know Paramahansa Yogananda
was many things,
but he was one of the initial people to come from India
to the United States and was part of the movement
of introducing yoga and meditation
and all these things that have become so integrated
into our culture at a time when these
were crazy brand new ideas.
Yeah, and that, like the 1920s,
he was coming here and-
And he would sit in these salons in Manhattan
and have these get togethers that are reminiscent of
that movie, "The Master."
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what comes to mind,
like what that vibe must have been like.
But just a beautiful, magnificent consciousness.
There's that headquarters on Mount Washington,
but there's also the Self-Realization Retreat Center
in Pacific Palisades where you can,
the grounds are open,
and there's this pond and you can go and meditate there.
And also the temple in Encinitas,
it's right on the beach.
Which is my favorite one.
Which is the surf spot right off of it.
Swami's.
It's called Swami's.
And I think a lot of people don't know that that's why
it's called Swami's.
No, I agree, but that-
'Cause he is the Swami.
So if you don't read the book, Ben,
make sure you stop by one of his sites.
You should go.
Yeah, you should read the book
and then go visit one of those sites.
Exactly, read the book.
Don't take, don't worry about me.
I'm the guy that the Self-Realization Fellowship
didn't even like.
(Rich) But you're an unlikely person to have
that kind of experience and then admit to it.
You know what I mean?
Like you have a practical, grounded perspective
over these things.
Yeah, well that happened.
So, that's very cool.
My Kerouac of choice is "The Dharma Bums."
I, "On the Road" was very important to me,
because it gives permission to be expansive.
It gives permission to reach for some expansive sense
of self and joy in the moment and not be someone who's
about collecting stuff and putting it in their stuff house.
And that's what you need to do.
Like I still am guided by that to some degree.
"The Dharma Bums" though,
it comes after "On the Road" has,
it is, "On the Road" is in the can.
Everyone loves it as publishers.
It's not out yet.
And he goes on one last road trip,
before it becomes this massive hit.
He's written, it it's all done,
and this is the next thing that he does.
And he does another cross country trip.
And he meets up with his buddies
in the Bay Area and Oregon,
and ends up as a lookout in a fire tower
in Washington state.
And there's a lot more meditation and mindfulness.
So this is where the Beats start to get credit
for bringing in Eastern practices
and mindfulness into their,
and meditation into their work, which became mainstreamed.
And I love "Dharma Bums."
"Island of the Blue Dolphins"
by Scott O'Dell is a classic for around here.
It's about, it's actually about a little Chumash girl
who is kind of moored and left behind
with her little brother on one of the Channel Islands here.
And it's what happens to her
as she fends for herself for over a decade,
I believe it is.
Or maybe its-
My daughter read that book in school.
Yeah, it's now, it's taught in school,
but I never read it until later.
I read it in maybe one big gulp
like sitting down in the sun.
It's like an adventure book.
So like, and, but it's so beautiful,
and it talks about the Channel Islands here.
So I love that book.
And how does, how she survived.
Incredible.
It's crazy.
Like I don't even wanna spoil anything.
It's very, it's sad at first,
but it ends up being quite incredible.
And then "Evening in Paradise" by Lucia Berlin.
who's an overlooked short story author.
I think I might have referenced her
with the Rachel Kushner stuff,
but she is, she was like,
she didn't have any hits.
She was like revered by her peers,
considered in like the '60s, '70,
maybe '70s and '80s considered one of these great,
the female Raymond Carver, short story writer,
but just couldn't get any traction commercially.
And had to do odd jobs basically our whole life
until she had a collection called,
"The Confessions of a Cleaning Woman,"
came out very late career when she
was like suffering health problems
from I think alcoholism was involved in that.
And she ends up having a best,
like late career bestseller,
and is a faculty at the University of Colorado.
But before that, she was a cleaning woman,
she was X, she was Y, she's like,
she lived this very outsize, huge life.
And "Evening in Paradise" is a second collection.
I think it came out posthumously.
But to me, it's my, is,
I enjoyed that one better than
the "Confessions of a Cleaning Woman."
Yeah, I haven't read that at all.
I'll have to check it out.
And that includes,
like she grew up a Diplomat's daughter in Chile.
She has this crazy life,
but it's semi-autobiographical stuff.
It is fiction.
So you just don't really know where the line is,
but it's a lot of fun.
You see what we did there?
What's that?
(iPad beeping)
Whoops, did I just call Siri?
I didn't say "Siri."
I said, I see what you,
"Do you see what you did there?"
Siri go away.
No, what did I do?
Just when everybody thought that this
was a Swimmer On conversation,
you reminded everybody that this is truly
a literary podcast.
(Adam laughing)
But now back to running.
Back to running.
Rich.
Switching it up,.
It's so confusing.
Telling him how to go
from road to trail.
What does your podcast do?
(Adam laughing)
My podcast?
What does?
No it's the question again.
Like what does your podcast?
I know, I know.
What does it do?
A little bit of everything I suppose.
Road to trail, don't overthink it.
It doesn't have to be that different.
I mean, I would say as Ricky Gates says,
fun over fast.
When you're on the road,
you have this tendency,
because it's a straight line or what have you,
to be really wed to the garmim,
all the metrics, what's your pace,
what's your cadence, what's your heart rate?
You can get really dialed in on that,
because it is,
you're limiting your variables.
But once you get on a trail,
all that goes out the window.
So I would encourage you.
I mean I don't know what your relationship is
to road running,
so maybe you're already cool with letting go of all of that.
For some, it's a challenge to just be present
for the experience.
Let go of pace, let go of cadence,
and just enjoy yourself and allow your mind
to wander and your senses to experience the environment.
It's not that different, but it does.
It depends on the trail of course.
Like, is it technical?
Is it flat?
Is it super steep?
You will in general have to be
a little bit more hypervigilant about your environments.
Like, are there crazy wild animals around here?
You have to be vigilant about your foot placement.
Are there roots and rocks that you can trip on?
One thing that was helpful to me when I was trying
to get used to running on trails,
is this idea of letting the trail work for you?
Like if you're running downhill on a road, it's one thing.
But on a trail,
you can kind of bound from rock to rock and kind of be more
in like surfing.
Like riding a wave,
as opposed to forcing yourself into a certain kind of pace.
Like gliding the descents,
learning how to be light on your feet and then delicate
on the ascents until you develop some kind of confidence.
And then I would just say it's more important that you
take safety precautions,
'cause especially if you're you're going on a road trip,
you're in the middle of nowhere,
or you want to go on this trail,
nobody knows where you are.
Who knows if any people are out there.
You get bit by a rattlesnake,
or you just fall down and twist your ankle,
and you can't run.
You gotta make sure that you have a phone with you,
that there is cell service.
There are things like on Strava,
you can do, like you can broadcast live,
or you can let certain people know where you are
so that there's some accountability
if something happens to you.
Oh nice.
Make sure that you have a hydration pack
and are taking care of all that kind of stuff.
And then one final little piece of practical advice
is to get the All Trails app, which is a great app.
And it shows you where all the trails are
wherever you're traveling,
so it makes that discovery process a little bit easier.
Beautiful, cool.
Are we done?
Any more books you wanna tell us about?
(Adam laughing)
Yeah I think?
No, I kept the books down to four this time.
You did.
Is that okay?
It was good though.
No, you're, you're in,
speaking of "Dharma Bums".
You are in your Dharma when you're discussing literature.
It's beautiful to watch
It's very kind of you to say that,
but reality,
I'm not an in-crowd literary person by any means.
It's not about that.
But I do love it.
How has the novel coming?
It's coming, man.
We're almost done with a third pass
and then there'll be a fourth pass,
and we'll keep going.
But the one thing about books that I love is like you can,
I was reading this at the same time I was reading something,
well, what's the mini series.
Like it was-
A mini series?
No, the "Thorn Birds"
No, no, the God,
why am I spacing on it?
The John Brown's,
The John Brown's series with Ethan Hawke.
Oh yeah,
I know what you're talking about.
What's it?
It has a crazy name.
I know exactly what you're saying.
Bird, ugh?
I know what it is.
We'll find it.
"Good Lord Bird."
Sorry about that.
Based on an amazing book.
Yes, and I was reading that
at the same time I was reading this,
and then I also got this new translation
of the "Data Chain,"
and I was thinking of like
what other mode do we have where you could be
in pre Civil War time, early 20th century Hawaii.
And whatever, like BC China, only books.
Nothing else can even come close to it.
Well, for virtual reality.
It's gonna catch up to that.
(Adam laughing)
Don't worry about the books.
Yes, that's true.
VR, VR is the next.
Yeah, just some tweak on the simulation.
Time travel.
That's right.
Would you do it?
Like if someone came in here right now
with a time travel portal and said,
we don't know when,
we can get you back,
We don't know how long it will take.
And you don't know,
do you know what era you're going into?
You get to choose the era?
I think we have a romantic attachment with,
to certain periods of time thinking
that they were better than they were.
That was never more evident than watching "The Nick."
You just see like,
I'm so glad that I didn't live in 1900.
It just looked awful.
Oh yeah.
Well there'd be plumbing issues.
Yeah, everybody's stank.
Everybody was dying of disease everywhere.
It was, like if you had a medical problem, good luck.
Like it was,
but you think like,
oh how cool would it be to live in Manhattan
in 1900 or 1920
or one of these times?
The Roaring Twenties and all of that.
But I think if you spend a week there,
when you've lived a life of iPads and Netflix,
you'd lose your mind.
So basically,
like if they said it could take a year to get you back.
Would I go back?
But you can choose where and when,
would you do it?
Probably,
just 'cause what an extraordinary experience.
Exactly, and where would you go?
Maybe Paris in the 1920s.
Nice.
I don't know.
Maybe that's not thinking broadly or more,
or creative way enough.
Hey sounds pretty cool to me.
Where would you go?
That's a good question.
I'm asking the questions around here Rich.
You are.
(Adam laughing)
Yeah, it's like on your literary podcast.
All right listen,
we've been going for well over two hours.
We're ending this thing.
We can talk about time travel and the simulation next time.
VR.
Let's do it.
What's better, VR or books?
R, R is better.
Debate.
R is always better than VR.
All right, man.
You feel good?
I do.
I feel good man.
I'm sorry for-
I'm over my languishing I think.
Did we de-languish you?
Thank you for helping me get over that.
I've been de-languished.
Fantastic.
Yes, thank you.
Wait 'til you try on this mask.
I can't, that's never gonna happen, never.
Cut, smash, cut to me on Instagram wearing that mask.
(Adam laughing)
Right?
Yes.
All right,
See, in two weeks,
maybe we might have to postpone,
because of the, you're gonna go see the Iron Cowboy.
I gotta date in Provo.
So we'll, yeah,
we might have to rearrange that.
Maybe not in two weeks.
We'll figure it out.
In the meantime, follow Adam on the internets
@AdamSkolnick.
Leave us a message with your question,
(424) 235-4626.
Check out the show notes on the episode page at richroll.com
for links to everything we talked about today.
We'll also put links up in the description below
if you're watching this on YouTube.
Speaking of YouTube,
subscribe to our channel on YouTube.
Subscribe to our Clips channel,
and you can find us on Apple, Spotify, all the places.
If you wanna be super generous, throw a few stars at us.
Say a few nice things.
I say that to friends and enemies alike.
Yes.
What else?
I think that's it.
Shout out, Brogan Graham.
Shout out to Brogan.
We work through, we're in a good place audience.
All of us, right?
Good, how has your short film practice going?
I sent a couple.
I sent out a couple.
We're on a group chat.
I sent a couple from the mountains.
But are you doing it with other people?
No, I have not expanded it out.
Yeah, that's the thing.
It's amazing to me how many of these Brogan has going.
(Adam laughing)
He's a full-time production studio.
I know.
And then he edits them and creates movies out of
like his library of-
He's got like,
you know what Brogran,
you have a very, very handsome creative group of people
that you're doing these with.
Yeah.
Thank you for including us or me.
Yeah, thank you.
We love you Brogan.
Yeah.
I gotta thank everybody who helped me
on the show today?
Yeah do it, do it.
Let's thank Jason Camiolo sitting right behind me,
audio engineer, production, show notes, interstitial music.
Jason has a tendency to wake up at 3:00 in the morning
and just to make sure that the podcast goes live.
Wow.
He goes overboard.
Blake Curtis, who creates the video version of the podcast,
has a pension for coming in Sunday afternoons
to make sure that the video is dialed up.
These guys work really hard.
Thank you to both of them.
I could do not do what I do without their help.
Jessica Miranda for graphics.
We got, who do we have in today?
Grayson.
Who do we have?
We have Grayson Wilder over here,
shooting portraits.
New on the team.
Thank you Grayson.
Georgia Wavey for copywriting DK
for advertiser relationships.
Theme music by Tyler Trapper and Harry.
We will see you back here.
When we see you.
We will be back here with another cool episode
in a couple of days until then,
namaste Paramahansa Yogananda.
Namaste.
Peace.
Plants.
Coyote